[Music]
oh
e
[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
a
n
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
ahahahahahahahahah
w
[Music]
oh
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks mag Mrs King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walks right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 they made a big mistake
oh and the bar is going up this is an
absolute Gem of a game Wesley saw has
done it he's going for the attack but
he's walked into Checkmate black can
play Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
my God what did we C
in it's been dramatic dream runs for
some heart breaks for others are we
expecting more twists and turns I'd say
heck yes welcome everyone to the Chessa
Masters I'm International Master T sa
alongside me as always my good friends
grandm Robert H and grandm David H guys
we're in for another big day of chess
four players facing elimination two will
be knocked out and a big big winnner
final David are you hyped I can't wait
Tanya it feels like it's all been
building up to this um of course uh
still so much to play for we've had the
underdog stories we've had Magnus Carson
in action uh what more could we ask for
it's been simply great so far and I'm
expecting more of the same Robert how
excited are you for today oh I'm pumped
and I've never heard David get that loud
before so I can tell that he is ready
for an excellent day of Chess
ahead it is going to be more drama on
the board as we got big matches coming
up four heavy weights in the losers
bracket have to F fight it out they're
on their lost life these are the
brackets going into our big Winners
final coming later today we started with
eight players in the winner semi-final
we saw Dennis lavic take down Jose
Martinez Magnus Carlson in a dramatic
Armageddon one against Vladimir fedos
they'll be facing each other in the big
Winners final it is the 17-year-old
Dennis lazovic the kid who's been on a
dream run against the biggest hurdle the
world number one Magnus but we start the
day with the losers bracket players on
their last live it will be Vladimir fosf
taking on Yan neishi and Jose Martinez
who has been playing Amazing chess in
the chessable Masters winning the planes
but yesterday he lost to D he will be on
his last life up against Ali RZA fuja
who knocked out Wesley so predictions
guys who are we expecting Robert to make
it through to the loser semi-finals
you're putting too much pressure on me
because we have for the second day in a
row some Heavy Hitters in the
elimination bracket Ali Raza fua he
survived against Wesley so Wesley made
one incorrect pawn move and that was
that and so for Ali RZA who's on his
last life I think he will be one of the
players to make it through he'll
continue his journey here at the
chesfield Masters David I don't know do
you agree with me or am I just going out
and a limb here I've got to say uh I
trust you Robert always and I do agree
in this regard it feels like uh things
are working on his uh on his side a bit
of luck in his favor and I've got to say
in the other match as well fed has been
on fire really really unlucky against
Magus Carson yesterday so I'm going to
say that his run might continue I would
love to see a rematch
potentially
of course uh Four Strong players hard to
predict but those my bets we're going to
be in for some awesome chest today
really pumped about it it was an
absolute roller coaster yesterday let's
rewind and set the tone for the action
that's coming up take a
look those players in the elimination
bracket now four of the world's best so
there's definitely going to be blood
spil that was a blunder from Wesley so
and his time in this tournament might be
done this is getting crazy where is the
check baate coming in do you just we
go what a finish that was sick for Mala
the night is coming the king is coming
but a mistake Now by Vash gra white Pawn
run suddenly wh's ahead Maxim Vash gra
resigns the Jeep arm is Unstoppable
Maxim is eliminated wh King actually
going to feel safe and sound or who
apparently there was a big blunder w wow
double question mark and black can
pretty much win on the spot it's game
over and it's match over Dennis lavic
advances through I see progress with a
helping hand but unfortunately again
you're playing Magnus Carson and he is a
Marathon Man
whoa lost on time are you kidding me if
the Rooks come off the board then the
last Pawn drops that's immediately a
drop Magnus progresses from this
Armageddon so close so
close in just a few more minutes the
players will be ready to go and the
these are the win probabilities for our
chable masters Magnus Carlson as always
a massive favorite to win the event
Robert what do you think are we
overstating it a little bit here or is
Magnus just
Unstoppable well with magnus's win
probability around 90% I have to say I
think that's accurate the other players
in the elimination bracket some super
strong names but they're on their last
life and Dennis lck he has the same
amount of time left as Magnus Carlson
but when you're facing Magnus perhaps
the greatest player of all time you have
your hands full so I have to say it does
look accurate to me it's hard to bet
against Magnus no matter what the format
is he's always always the big favorite
and yesterday what a match it was
against Vladimir fedel let's take a look
at our post match stats with that big
fight right there David it was a match
that could that could have gone either
way Magnus took the early lead but fedos
he really fought back
ah it really went down to the wire I
jinxed Magnus actually Yesterday by
calling him the marathon man just before
he lost on time in game four but
ultimately in the Armageddon he was able
to pick up the speed pick up the
accuracy uh when it really mattered and
look how close it was there Magnus was
critical about his own play but 93%
accuracy not bad at all and fed not far
behind It ultimately came down to that
Armageddon came down to a rush Against
Time and um yeah I think fed sa with a
bit more luck things could have gone his
way Magnus as he said yesterday needs to
improve today against Dennis lazic to
ensure a victory and we saw one blunder
per side that was on the board but
perhaps the biggest blunder of all was
not included there it was a loss on time
for Magnus Carlson who said he just
didn't feel like he was in it that he
was struggling that he was fortunate he
survived he won that match so he does
have his two lives left a not in it
Magnus is he still the second best
player in the world we get the answer to
that today he plays against Dennis
lazovic Dennis has been so in formed
Magnus said it himself it's like he beat
the Murderers Row what a performance
he's had and that matchup is coming on
later today Magnus Carlson said he needs
to do better today than he did yesterday
and of course there are players who are
fighting on their last life one of them
the two times World Championship
Challenger Yan nepom Nishi he will be
playing against Vladimir FV and
yesterday he had quite a match against
Maxim Vash lra Again David it was Yan
who was on the back foot he lost the
first he lost the first game and then a
dramatic Armageddon saw a big turnaround
what did you make of that finish yeah it
was brilliant from Yan again with with
his back against the wall in must-win
situations he really upped his level and
we see it there uh decent accuracy for
both sides but ultimately decided by
those brilliancies from Yan naom Nishi
in the second game a queen sacrifice
with a Checkmate and in the Armageddon
making the second last mistake it was
bashid de gra who blundered finally and
ultimately Yan progresses so very close
those two Rivals we'll see Vash gra in
future throughout the tour I'm sure but
it's Yan who's Clinging On to survival
and he needs to improve again today to
uh maintain his place here at the
Chesser bow Masters yeah for maxim VRA
that was a heartbreaking moment so close
to getting that Armageddon Victory but
it's not over till it's over in chess
and that's what we saw Yan she stays
alive in the chessable Masters we will
have the loser semi-finals today we
start with that later of course Robert
we've got a big matchup coming on with
the 17-year-old Dennis lvic taking on
the world number one now of course
Magnus a big favorite today what does
Dennis need to do to make you think that
he's got a chance against Magnus today
well Magnus Carlson is nearly double the
age of his opponent that's not something
that we say very often but Dennis lck he
is a teenage ation he's been on a tear
and his ratings throw them out the
window except perhaps that chess.com
rapid rating nearly 2800 up there with
the best of them so I think for Dennis
his future is so bright but his present
and his recent history oh watch out
because as Magnus himself said he took
down some of the very best players in
the world he's a scary guy he's not
going to lose without an absolute
fight well we saw them in Toronto
playing over the board and actually it
was very close Magnus won eventually
against Dennis but Dennis got a draw
there in Toronto and even his defeat
against Magnus was just in the final
stages a last minute blunder so
definitely anything
possible we all know Magnus lives
rentree in most of the players heads but
the younger generation tends to fight
that and Dennis lazovic has said he's
got no Heroes he's got no Idols in the
Chess World it's going to be a big fight
Dennis needs to keep that attitude be
Fearless on the board and he's been
quite the Conqueror this chessable
Masters
Robert he's been just a beast I mean
there are no other words to describe his
performance thus far beating some of the
biggest names in chess starting with
Hikaru Nakamura then Anish giri Maxim
vashir lra for good measure and let's
not forget Jose Martinez so Dennis lavic
he's been a kid on a mission and can
that mission continue today it might be
Mission Impossible when it's against
Magnus Carlson but hey why not the
magical run may continue and he may see
his way all the way to the Grand Final
oh my gosh that could be if that happens
it will be the biggest upset that we've
seen in the Champions Chester the way
danis lavic is playing you cannot write
that one off and of course once again
that will come on later the Dennis
versus Magnus matchup we will start off
with the losers quarterfinals and you
mentioned Jose Martinez he's been having
a great run as well great performance in
the Swiss planes he also started off
well but yesterday against Dennis lawick
in that game one I think it all just
turned around for Jose losing a winning
position it sees him in the losers
bracket and he takes on alira fuja David
on paper alira has got to be a favorite
where do you see Jose's
chances on paper fuia is the favorite
but uh Jose Martinez just needs to
channel that form we've seen throughout
the last few days from him yes there was
a blip yesterday it felt like Martinez
was trying a bit too against laic but um
if he maintains that form if he kind of
regains his balance he's got a chance
fua who we see in front of us now has
been up and down missed an inconsistent
sparkling world class play on his day
but also a few blunders here and there
so Jose has to hope that he catches fua
uh on an off day a bit off guard maybe
in a quieter position where Fu's
strengths aren't allowed to
shine ala fua lost to Vladimir FV went
down to the losers bracket and then
eliminated one of the best in the world
eliminated Wesley so there's definitely
going to be a big fight between these to
Jose Martinez he's flexing a little bit
right now on the camera stretching
getting ready uh body language what do
you make of Al resar he looks very
focused David looks focused and I think
he's extremely determined uh to put that
inconsistent form behind him and uh in
the meantime the others other losers
quarterfinal uh fed against yan neomi
yan slightly older but so level there in
terms of ratings and uh maybe that
head-to-head Robert just slightly in
Yan's favor uh giving him the upper hand
it doesn't surprise me Yan is the higher
rated between the two at least over the
board but as you look at their ratings
online they're almost identical 2812 for
the big fish 2011 for Yan napesi so this
is a very close call between two great
players two players who can win this
whole thing despite being in the losers
bracket and we saw how close both of
them have been and Y pomi he was out
just on the verge of being eliminated
against Maxi V sh gr and one Hasty king
move alloud Yan the two-time world
championship Challenger to survive and
he didn't just survive he Advanced and
I'm telling you don't count him out
because he can beat anyone in this field
including his former world champion
rival Magnus Carlson
not many players in the world can boast
about winning the candidates twice back
to back the two times World Championship
challenges you mentioned it is all about
him finding his form finding his rhythm
and yesterday the way he checkmated
Maxim V lra in that second game it feels
like he has ultimately found it but the
armagen was a bit up and down for fetv
it just feels that he's been more
consistent than Yan is that fair to say
Robert that so far FV has has been the
more consistent player well the reason I
like this matchup is they kind of have
the similar style as that when they're
on their best game they just Crush their
opponents but sometimes they get a
little bit too feisty they just want
that Victory they play aggressive
tactical Styles and I mean for federos
of he was really close to beating Magnus
Carlson but a day before that against
Ali Rea fua he probably should have lost
that if you repeated that game 10 times
I think he loses nine out of the 10 but
that one was good enough despite being
down two full Pawns H and we often talk
about styles of players David Robert
saying that these two have a similar
style how do we expect the opening how
important will it be for these players
the opening approach that they bring on
and what are you
expecting uh I'm expecting the Catalan
opening because Yan pomi is wearing his
Barcelona Football top but fed sa is the
one who starts with white uh of course
he can freestyle he plays every first
move pretty much um he has this really
unique Style Magus mentioned it Robert
you highlighted it there and I think Yan
there we go Pawn to D4 if Yan brings his
world championship repertoire he will be
in good stead here we see the nimzo
Indian defense blacks Bishop coming out
to pin the White Knight early fed have
used this move Queen to C2 yesterday
against Magnus Carson we see a quick
trade and uh White has the bishop pair
but black Ahad in development uh a lot
of theory here Tanya you're a D4 player
uh must have seen this position at some
point yes and I like these positions
with black uh and also let's remind
everyone before we Deep dive into the
ideas that this is a best of two so the
margin for error is so little you have
to keep things under control take
calculated risk because to come back is
never easy with such few matches and
they we see after 86 one set of minor
pieces has been traded off white of
course had the option to even fall back
with the bishop but going for a more
direct approach here Knight to F3 and
Robert he Yan slows down before
capturing on C4
does that surprise you well I think it's
what we've been talking about the
margins are thin here with a just two
game matches if you make one slip in the
opening and give Vladimir fedos of the
advantage you may not come back from it
and look at this queen on C5 what an
annoying piece to deal with it's just
sitting here saying you can't touch your
B Pawn to develop your Bishop you K it
because your knight is loose you can't
easily move the Knight because the C7
Pawn is behind it all the while you're
protecting your Pawn on D4 so Yan he's
got his face in his hands right now
David have you seen this queen C5 idea
before and has Yan is the more important
question uh I must admit I'm not too
familiar with this queen C5 move as far
as I was aware uh dropping back the
queen to C3 was the main move uh in that
position that's appeared in multiple uh
Master games the whole idea is firstly
as you mentioned to keep pressure on
this Black Knight but also to clamp down
to stop black breaking out with E5 and
that has very much been set set up now
with this last move Black's Rook
activating he's pretty much guaranteeing
yand pomi that he wants to throw that
ewn forward to develop the black Bishop
just to open lines towards the white
king while it's still stuck in the
center and um yeah certainly Yan ponesi
was surprised I believe a rare move but
uh after recomposing himself correctly
just improving a piece correctly setting
up a threat and I'm equally surprised to
see feder of think now because if this
was prepared if this was home cooking as
we say Quin to C5 something he studied
four then surely he would have examined
what to do after Black's most natural
move Rook to E8 and there we go Knight
into E5 blocking Black's main idea it's
pretty much one side saying what they
want to do next and feder shutting the
door in his face um what do you make of
this Knight exchange now uh Robert this
is uh changing the pawn structure
changing the dynamic of the game well
white has these double pawns that may
seem bad but white just has more active
pieces despite the fact that the king
remains in the center so black offers a
queen trade White will likely bring a
rook on a semi-open line it's about
developing these pieces on the king side
that can't get out so Tanya you at first
glance I don't love double pawns but I
like activity open files what do you
make of this position because the engine
off to the side of the board here says
it's pretty level would you rather have
white or black in the setup I started
earlier I do like these lines with the
black pieces in the nimzo and I think
the main idea for black was to get E5 in
which now has been stopped at the cost
of these double Pawns but while white
has been doing that it allows black to
finish development for example all right
he's taken on C5 I was thinking of ideas
of actually sacrificing on C7 with white
King still in the center maybe we'll see
that because the main problem in this
position for black is to develop that
light Square Bishop that is the absolute
key and very often in these structures
you can even give up the C7 Pawn open up
the sea line to do just that for
development for example a move like B6
comes to my mind or you're highlighting
the move Bishop D7 which the more I see
I like that one as well the main point
is that if white was to get greedy with
the C7 Pawn your entire King side is
still in the house you haven't moved a
single piece black can quickly take out
the bishop can bring the Rook to the
open line and very often that gives more
than enough compensation for the
pawn I'm with you I think that's a
viable option whether you play B6 or
Bishop D7 Yan he's sitting in for
another think because this is a critical
moment sometimes when we review games
David we quickly just press the next
button just go through it but this could
be a gamechanging moment whether he
sacrifices the pawn or plays rookie s
I'm going to ask you the question David
knowing your answer you love material so
I'm assuming you'd play a move like Rook
E7 or Pawn to C6 here to keep that pawn
you know me too well Robert uh I
wouldn't hesitate I would keep that
black porn on the board but I'm not
yanomi um I know him very well and I
think his Instinct he's mulling it over
now his instinct is to sacrifice to play
actively dynamically all of these top
players they want to play the most
ambitious move they don't want to just
sit there passively defend let their
opponent dictate the pace of the game to
have uh the upper hand to have more fun
um so I agree with t Yan is definitely
considering it um he's no you know he's
not a timid scaredy cat like me but oh I
jinx it there we go R7 he is a twoy cat
lately defending the pawn and black is
passive I think Yan just made this move
for you David he knows you're
commentating on it this is your style
he's playing according to to what you
want him to do right now but it also
makes a lot of sense because again white
is so far behind in development that
black perhaps has the time to do it but
this is what I was afraid of because now
anytime you move the B Pawn which he's
done it white can perhaps put the bishop
on G2 for example right now itself you
can take the Rook on C5 white will
capture The Rook on A8 Black's the one
with the double pawns the bishop still
on C8 I'm just wondering who does this
trade favor Robert yeah this would
definitely favor white I know we were
seeing how White's double pwn Pawns in
Center weren't so bad those double
isolated pawns for black would have been
awful so Rook B8 I think that's the
proper response this Rook now has to
slide back as it's under attack and that
does give black the time to push this
backwards Pawn or trade off the light
Square Bishops I actually think that Jan
is handling this perfectly there could
still be some sort of attacking chances
on the king side if Jan isn't careful
eventually a rook sliding to G1 and pawn
to G5 but so far everything looks fine
in Black's position it's about
developing trading off key pieces and
speaking of Rook D7 David that is an
excellent move I was thinking Bishop to
B7 but he says your best piece is
actually your Rook rather than your
Bishop staring Into Thin Air love moves
like Rook to D7 despite the fact that
you move the same piece numerous
times Rooks become the most powerful
pieces often in the end game it's all
about open lines open files and that
open dline for the white Rook uh was
ready uh to be utilized and now just
neutralizing the opponent's piece I
wouldn't be surprised to see the black
king uh step towards the center as well
in the next few turns just to again
challenge there we go King to f8 to
control those key entry squares the
white Rook wants to enter wants to creep
into the black camp but the black king
is going to shut the door and white was
kind of obliged there to Castle himself
the white king now not too happy stuck
on one of the flanks Kings want to be in
the center it's easier to Direction
switch up Direction later but uh it was
more important to conect the Rooks so um
I've got to say this is going in Black's
favor on the camera you can't really
tell who the happier player is but
fed I fear for him here long term if all
the Rooks disappear black is simply
going to win Black's queenside porns
those three versus two uh on that Left
Flank they're going to March forward and
uh we talked about double pawns earlier
Tanya why is King side majority far
harder to utilize that's really well put
that if all the pieces are created and
it's a pure King Pawn ending black is
essentially a pawn up it's so much
easier for black to create a passer it's
just a winning end game so white needs
to be careful to me Robert it looks like
it might be time for white to start
thinking about a pawn roll on the king
side that's why you had the majority
you're already thinking about pushing
that F Pawn pushing that H Pawn get F4
F5 in because if you don't do anything
then David's idea of trading pieces
could become a big reality while FV has
a think in this position
Robert update us with what is happening
on the other big matchup between Ali
Resa and Jose again two players on their
lost lives yeah this game it's deep into
the end ending where both sides are
trying to stop the other's plans and
here on the right hand side of our
screen we see that Jose Martinez with
the white pieces against aliv zaa it's a
pretty level game with white having a
knight versus a black Bishop so as I
look across these matches so far there's
been little separation between these
players and I I just think that it's a
pretty balanced
Affair looks pretty much symmetrical the
pawn structure here um I'm looking at
the cameras as well both look pretty
calm feels like Jose Martinez doesn't
want to take any risk here with white um
it's after all as you mentioned Tanya a
two game match losing with white would
be a cardinal in here you cannot get
away with it um then again the Symmetry
we talked about open lines white is the
one with slightly more active pieces
White's Queen more active than its
counterpart and white occupying the only
open Line uh the E file so question mark
attached to this last move Tanya can you
see any specific reasons or um what why
could that be a mistake to me it looks
like such a natural move because you
want to make sure your Queen's free to
move around a little bit your D Pawn's
protected Rook d8 would be a move that
we'd all want to make in this position
you put the Rook on a nice Square it's
actually doing something there but I
think here are the Eternal question and
I'm going to throw it to both of you
here it's Knights versus Bishop in these
kind of position what do we prefer do we
prefer the Knight or do we prefer the
Bishop Robert I'm gonna stop with you
well the bishop is kind of biting on
granite with this Pawn chain here is
Right In The Bishop's path so there's no
good useful diagonal to work with a
knight E5 that wasn't the move so I
think we should analyze just bring up
the analysis board for a second because
this move gets an X I'm going to look
and see what was the Improvement
ever so quickly and it says that B4
that's why Rook d8 earned a question
mark is that white should try to Spring
free a pass Pawn if black were to take
on B4 now we see how clear it is that
pawn will push a rook trade at some
point will help white uh clear the road
for that pass Pawn so this I wouldn't
really consider it a you know a huge
mistake from White it's hard to spot
these ideas and it creates weaknesses
but David now that we see it grinding
like a grandmas it could have been a
good start by pushing some of these
outside
B4 would have been a really instructive
really classy move switching Focus there
um with black off balance suddenly
playing on the queen side but very hard
to see as you say probably the most
difficult thing in chess is knowing when
to kind of go for these exchanges when
to change the structure uh when to start
taking action when it looks like you you
can just slowly maneuver and improve and
I did prefer the queen of Knight combo
over the queen of Bishop the Knight is
the only piece that can act in a way a
queen cannot so Queen and Knight
together um do often work wonders but
now that the bishop and Knight have both
disappeared fewer imbalances here white
is only playing with one kind of small
uh kind of aesthetic Advantage at least
that's the open file but if Quin
disappear I don't think you can really
profit from uh that small thing so um
yeah the problem for Jose Martinez he
wants to kind of drop the White Queen
back kind of set up a battery along the
eile but there is a white hanging Pawn
on A4 so he's kind of tied down um Tanya
Queen
exchange like Robert said I love to
grind like a Grandmaster in an end game
to push to try to look for these small
advantages but I'm struggling to see any
I'm going to first ask the burning
question who came up with the name grind
like a
grandmas I can uh give away a little
trade secret it was originally the title
was meant to be grind like gelfand
because uh when I was young he grounded
me down in some long Seven Hour end
games he did the same to Magnus a few
times but in the end grind like a grandm
was a bit more catchy so uh GLG that's
what we call it I love it and we keep
alluding to that book that you
coauthored with Magnus Carlson and I
think we might be seeing another grind
coming out in this now even if the
queens were to get traded would it
completely be leveled because I see one
open file white has total control of it
the Rook from E5 can give a check and
maybe start targeting the queenside pawn
it looks like the black Rook even if the
Queens are traded off will be more
passive at least for a while and
Robert's idea of eventually getting B4
in white might be the first one to
create a passer even if it's an end game
I think White's got something to play
for here
David certainly um you never give up
that's the kind of 101 of the grind uh
it's like in life I'm sure all the
viewers at home sometimes you have to
work a bit harder you have to work
overtime at the office you have to kind
of really dig deep even when you're not
feeling it too much you have to find the
energy from somewhere that's what Jose
Martinez has to do right now like you
say Tanya Quin exchange whoa I was about
to say was inevitable take the Queens
off and then try to look for small
advantages White's King coming to the
center instead he gambits a pawn Robert
I was saying earlier this was pretty
much impossible should black just snack
on that straggler on A4 Jose raising his
eyebrows there do you think he missed it
is this intentional it's intentional and
it's kind of what you were hinting at
earlier that these players they will
give up material if it means that they
get active play so just to put this
sample line on the board and ala he
doesn't have to take the pawn although I
think that White's intentions are clear
if Queen takes Pawn on A4 if we can just
show this quickly The Rook comes up to
E7 and now we see the White Queen
joining C7 is loose if you try to
protect this Pawn by just pushing it to
safety you can already see that the
black queen is out of play and white can
even play Alpha zero style to try and
get after the black king so the engine
doesn't seem phased it says that black
can snack on that pawn but I would
personally be a little bit worried with
having my queen offside like this even
if it's objective equality I think
practically speaking Tanya it does seem
like white has a little bit more fun the
Aon not so relevant just yet it's a
really nice Point made by you you
sacrifice a pawn for activity and it
really feels like Jose style as well to
get into these kind of positions but
it's also Ali rzza style he picks it up
because white was in any case planning
to go rookie 7 a difficult threat to
fight and now this is going to be quite
the fireworks on the board unexpected so
over the last few moves it looked like a
very slow position it's blowing up the
queen from E2 is going to step on to F3
start targeting the F7 Pawn right now
black needs to answer the most immediate
question how are you defending C7 the
first move that came to my mind was slip
up with a rook to D7 you want to
challenge that Rook on the seventh rank
but I think that's dangerous because
then white can give a check on E8 you
come up with your king to G7 Queen E5
and suddenly we see that the only move
black will have is F6 and I think David
with Rook E7 check it just felt like it
would be too dangerous for white so
instead we've got the move C5 and my
question to you is can white go Queen to
F3 ignore the center well he answers it
he wants to take on the C5 Pawn
instead he actually preferred your move
there Tanya I think he might well try it
now on the next turn there we go still
this Checkmate in two threat uh the F7
Pawn is hit needs to be defended and uh
FIA notice how he's going passive here
out of necessity I talk about divorce
here with the black king The Black Queen
they're so far apart from each other and
that spells trouble so you often have to
put a piece passive uh just while the
queen is absent from the defense and
here we go equal material yet again the
pawn has been snapped off but things are
disappearing I think F has calculated
really really well that he can liquidate
the whole queenside that all those
queenside pawns will just fall off the
board and uh why is he hesitating surely
he's going to push that Aon now maybe
he's just slightly afraid that the white
Rook will zoom over and uh
prevent that pawn from continuing its
Advance still I don't know Robert I
would slightly prefer white in this
position I definitely would prefer to
have the white side of this position
just because white has the activity so I
have to say both players playing a
nearly perfect game uh Jose he went for
the activity there were some practical
problems that still need to be solved
from the black side but I think that
there we go as about to say one little
precise move away from Full equality for
Ali Raza the queen protects the pawn it
also also protects the king side this F7
Pawn which has been a weak point and
puts pressure on the C3 Pawn so I do
think in the near future we'll just see
pieces as you would say David hoovered
off the board and we are likely to see a
split point so Tanya I mean it's been a
fun game in this one but I just I get
the sense that the life is kind of
sucked out of it although Alpha zero
style play on the king side Jose is not
going to let this game fizzle out
without more of a fight I agree but I
think black can just simply stop that
Alpha Zer esque plan of H5 with pushing
his own Pawn up the board and after that
I just see a symmetrical Pawn structure
black playing H5 here seems to stop all
uh White's dreams on the king side
eventually I'm uh foreseeing the a pawn
being traded off for the cwn can we say
that draw is not too far away in this
one looks that way I think a draw is
almost inevitable and uh maybe we take a
step out and go to the B ey view because
the other game uh while the draw is
still possible there it's heating up
it's a pawn race it's only Rooks and
pawns left and suddenly look at that
black king on the left hand board fed
against yand pomi all these King walks
we've seen throughout the tournament so
far throughout division one Black's King
has entered started grabbing pawns and
uh temporarily black is a pawn ahead
evaluation bar on his side as well um
Robert what do you make of this has fed
have just lost control or was this an
intentional gamble on his part well he
we got into an end game where those
double pawns were not good and they're
doubled no more because black is up a
Pawn on the left hand side of our screen
so Tanya she said she wanted from the
black side the whole way she thought
that that opening was good for yand
pishi and it's proven to be the case so
Vladimir fedos of this is a rocky start
it hasn't been good from him he is
trying to challenge black on the seventh
rank with his Rook but it it feels like
Jan with precise play and with two
minutes and change on his clock he
should get the job done
I think this is one of those games which
is going to become a model game for the
nimzo Indian Queen C5 a new idea tried
but it didn't really need lead anywhere
and I think the way Yan handled it
trying to get the E5 break in then how
he developed the queenside Bishops and
now look at this King this Rook Pawn end
game they often say that peace activity
the king activity and The Rook activity
in these kind of end games is worth a
pawn here black already has an extra
pawn and Yan wants to keep as many of
those pawns alive on the king side I see
some real winning chances in this one
David what do you make of it do you
think this is closer to a draw or a Yan
win I just love the way Yan's been
playing I think especially after these
last couple of moves it's uh pretty much
guaranteed to be a win now the black
pawns on the king side four versus two
there they're going to start running um
in the meantime small update the other
game we were following did as predicted
end in a draw uh Quin came off pawns
came off dead equality there so this is
the last game we've got left in the
losers quarterfinal and yeah just Yan I
love that F5 move just a couple of turns
ago just push pawns when in doubt if you
don't know what to do it's the end game
get as close to promotion as possible
and that's what fed is trying to do now
and the problem is connected P pawns the
black king is going to Shepherd his own
pawns forward and Black's Rook is doing
a fantastic job later of just sliding
behind White's runner on the B file um I
think it's a race but black is just too
far ahead even if black were to lose his
Rook for the white B Pawn in the near
future Black's pawns by then would be
too far down the board so uh this one I
think he's almost got it in the back
he's done the hard work Go Active with
your king everyone in the end game
that's uh how to yeah that's how to stay
on the front foot looks good Robert I
loved this move this latest move King to
G3 I'm sure Pawn takes Pawn on G4 was
also winning but you're already up
material and it's not about grabbing
more pawns it's about pushing them to
the other side so instead of stealing a
Pawn on G4 say let me just push and now
yes he could take this Pawn on H3 after
The Rook takes the pawn he can bring his
King back and then push his passers I
don't see why you would even waste any
time push this one all the way up the
board Jan says all right I I just feel
like it's important to take this one it
doesn't change the Dynamics of the game
it doesn't change the evaluation Tanya
Yan has done everything right in this
game his accuracy has been spoton I was
saying it's going to be a model game for
nimzo in I think it's going to be a
model game for how you play a rook B
ending we've been highlighting the pce
activity as well that F Pawn moving
forward white will have to give the Rook
for that pawn black will give his own
Rook for the B Pawn and then finally
that one extra Pawn the G Pawn will
decide the game and we see both pawns
moving forward this is just a matter of
a couple of moves and uh I think this is
busted for fedos he needs more than a
miracle to save this one he needs more
than 14 seconds as well time is not on
his side either he needs more pawns more
time everything and there we go
resignation black was about to make a
new Queen npish she takes the lead
impressive game there impressive end
game technique yeah really good stuff by
Yan Nei starts with a win with the black
pastes in a best of two he's got white
in the next one and needs only a draw to
keep him going in this event for fedal
sa that's big danger he has to win on
demand meanwhile Ali Rea and Jose
Martinez Robert an active game but ended
peacefully there was some good chess in
that game but little can be done when
both players are playing precise chess
so a draw between Jose and ala a fair
result and yand Pals just outplayed his
opponent starting in the end game the
worst Pawn structure came back to haunt
Vladimir who he it was his own doing he
played in offbeat variation and
unfortunately it was him who got beaten
so a great start for yanomi that's for
sure and it really wasn't a great start
for yanami in at the start of division
one he really struggled on day one but
then yesterday his comeback Victory
against Maxim V lra and his start today
I think this is the Yan that we love to
see and this is the Yan that can fight
to become the champion of the chessel
Masters David what are the chances of
fedos to come back in this match and how
do you think he can make it happen going
to be tough for FV losing with white we
said it earlier that is the worst
possible start and Yan Naomi he's played
these World Championship matches he's
got a fantastic repertoire so many
weapons there he knows how to shut down
games um so I think for fed he'll need
to launch the first surprise he'll need
to somehow provoke Yan into some Muddy
Waters where it's not a simple path
towards a draw and the longer it goes on
the one downside we've seen from yand
pishi throughout his career some nerves
do creep in he's consistently been the
runner up of big big events and uh you
just need to kind of just hold him off
as long as possible I think a long game
will favor fed but Yan with white if he
can lock it down if he can simplify
neutralize Black's winning chances
early an uphill struggle so Yan big big
favorite here but F say of the big fish
he's got to swim in a bigger pond in
this game and he's got to become a shark
for
sure Duffy needs to play some big moves
and get a big win in to take it into
Armageddon and we're off it's the
Sicilian that is at least a good news
not only for chess fans but also for
fedio that means that he will get some
up l in it will probably be a
complicated middle game and just as I
say that Robert it's the Rosal Lio by
Yan Smart Choice from Yan naon mry
because instead of allowing this to
venture into those tactical Waters of a
dragon where there are exchange
sacrifices and checkmating ideas look at
this position thus far no Pawn tension
he hasn't actually pushed his Pawn to D4
and fedos says you are not going to do
that I have the central clamp so I would
say both sides should be relatively
happy because as David said fed wants a
long game he proved yesterday that
against Magnus Carlson he can win in 100
plus move battles but for Yan pishi he
doesn't have to worry about his King
being checkmated so I would say pluses
for both David I know You' have
experience in these quiet type positions
who do you think is happier about the
opening stage I think Yan objectively
will be thinking that white has an
advantage after all white has castled
the king White's pieces the knights the
light Square Bishop that're out in the
center we always say that control the
Midfield control the center of the board
and you're H going to be in good stead
for the middle game he controls this
nice Square they are highlighting there
Robert big outpost on a light Square in
the middle of the board so kind of
taking the emotion out taking the
earlier result out I think Yan is happy
but uh fev cannot complain he's got all
of the pieces all 32 pieces still on
this board right now he's expanding
gaining space on the queen side he's got
some advantages of his own and more
importantly the game is alive it's
totally fresh I can guarantee neither
players studied this position before
despite yand pomnish speed um but for
black okay a big hit on that Queen he
needs to react he's played very quickly
up to this point but taking that Knight
in the center does look fraught with
danger and uh he might just have to go
for it he might have to kind of leave
the king in the center no he moves his
Queen instead um yeah I was trying to
talk purely about how the players are
feeling but now it's suddenly become
critical already some real calculation
to be
done Tanya I'm wondering I was going to
ask you are we going to see G takes F6
here I'd love to I think the fans would
love to see that happen the commentators
would love it and the fact that
F the fact that he hasn't picked up that
night instantly we might be seeing that
appear on the board and that would mean
it would be an absolute wild position
black destroying the pawn structure on
the king side for the open G line the
more he thinks he's reaching out for his
Mouse right now will he play it safe
capture it with the queen or will we see
a g Tak after he goes for the queen
Queen takes Knight I'm disappointed
Robert well I think it's the best move
objectively he probably wanted the play
G takes like in in my heart I want to go
all out for the attack but it was
strategically very unsound so he is
choosing the correct continuation his
position is much worse as David
highlighted white is castled controls
the center has more pieces developed and
black has just been shuffling around
with the queen so this is a clear
Advantage now for yand PMI his latest
move A4 somehow uh it wasn't best and
well fed he's not responding with the
most accurate moves that's the nature of
the game when you have to win or you're
eliminated you you get into this state
of mind where the best move may get
close to a draw so let's play some a
move that's speculative but at least
forces my opponent to calculate and I
think that both players are handling the
match situation
well I love that moment where you both
kind of in sync suggested G takes F6 um
I mean it wouldn't even be on my radar
but that's the type of move that
unexpected option often kind of going
against conventional wisdom you need to
just throw out there confuse your
opponent a bit I think feda feared if he
played an ugly move like that one
earlier that if he lost people would
have been you know mocking oh do you not
understand chess do you not understand
double pawns are bad so he's played what
should be correct but look at this the
evaluation bar now rising in White's
favor because he's profited he's used
his uh his kind of development advantage
to open up the Center when you're ahead
uh when you control more Central squares
if things explode open up you're in
better position to uh kind of utilize
and look at this Knight jumping into F5
now that's the blue arrow highlighted by
the computer saying it's by far the best
move I'm also going to jump out and say
it's one of the most natural moves a
knight on F5 Black's King might not
survive question mark there White's porn
will throw throw itself forward to F4 in
the near future as well o i really fear
look at that black light Square Bishop
undeveloped the black Dart Square Bishop
is a target for the marauding porns
Tanya um I know you're a great attacker
you must be salivating at the prospect
here of throwing those pieces forward
I'm flattered that you say that David
but I have to agree I mean just look at
White's position and yes visually it
looks amazing but even you can just see
exactly why it is Black's spond
structure worse than white compare each
of white species to Black species that
Bishop on D5 an absolute monster once
that Knight lands on F5 that's not a
knight anymore that's a Ian right there
black will have to find ways to
neutralize that maybe a move like 97
might help but it means more waste of
time which would give white the time to
actually go in with the idea of the pawn
Avalanche that you were earlier talking
about F4 E5 coming in the bishop
eventually landing on to D4 I just feel
like White's playing everywhere doesn't
rush in with Knight F5 first putting
pressure onto C6 and it might not be the
most accurate move but I think it's a
diff it's also a practical approach and
it just keeps all the Trump in White's
position meanwhile black doesn't trade
on D4 not allowing Bishop D4 which would
have hit the queen on F6 but falls back
with the Knight are we expecting the
bishop to retreat Robert or will he just
keep it there I would be tempted to
retreat make a move like Bishop back to
B3 but then I see that the black Bishop
can finally develop and poke at the
White Center some somehow things are
getting a little bit out of hand for
yanami uh the engine suggest that he's
better here that he hasn't spoiled his
position but it's getting complicated it
was locked up and now it's open and
there's a bishop staring at the white
king this queen on F6 is staring through
the night at this loose Pawn on B2 and
even if objectively you can give up this
Pawn on B2 it gets scary when black has
this passer not too far away from it so
I'm looking at this position with a
fresh set of eyes David I think fedos of
he feels locked in and like he suddenly
has chances because he's well heading
the clock and the position is becoming a
mixed bag
chess is all about momentum now he jumps
into F5 with his Knight but was it a
move too late now this uh I'm trying to
work it out I don't think it's quite a
pawn sacrifice but it is a big committal
decision um that's the thing Yan his
position was too nice in a way with
white he didn't want to do anything he
didn't want to spoil anything he just
moved his Rook to C1 what could be more
natural an open file but sometimes yeah
if you take your finger off the button
for a second or two the momentum
switches and um I think he's trying to
recorrect the course of this game by uh
throwing his Knight in maybe we jump in
here robertt and show the idea uh behind
this knight jump if black takes twice on
that square eliminates the White Knight
and then tries to snap up a
pawn okay well yeah this looks pretty
good for black but there are two
problems one Bishop takes F7 check it
allows the White Queen to hit a loose
piece on D6 loose pieces drop off and
that Bishop will fall but there's also
Bishop aiming in the other direction
because this Rook is trapped thanks to
both both of these bishops from the
white side so it's funny how I was first
staring at the king side then I saw the
evaluation was so high there must have
been something better and it's that this
Rook is trapped no safe squares
available to it and thus white wins
material what a position this is and I
do not believe that fedos is going to
fall for this because as we mentioned
even Bishop takes F7 check instead looks
very good to my eyes but after the trade
of knights on F5 if we get this position
it's up to Vladimir to find some useful
looking move Bishop A7 that will trap
the Rook if you're not careful that
actually is a threat on the board and so
Vladimir now he has his work cut out for
him after the swap of
nights big moment and he solves the
problem of that threat by offering a
trade of light Square Bishops and uh
here we go those Bishops have left the
board it does look like white has an
advantage but let's uh zoom out of this
one temporarily we also have another
game going in the losers quarterfinals
and uh here we see actually almost
symmetry in terms of the evaluation bars
uh the the first thing I looked over at
it looks like fua has an advantage but
it's a different type of advantage to
npom Nishi uh the board we see on the
right there fuja against Martinez very
very blocked white has more space hence
the advantage but uh still a lot to play
for um what do you make of this Tanya
the body language the clock times the
kind of first glance at the position I
think it's really interesting that
White's the one with double pawns but in
this particular case the double ponds
actually give white an edge a chance
because opens up the aile and creates a
target for white on that A5 Pawn White's
got these long-term ideas are perhaps
even doubling up on the aile but at
least for now it's making sure that
Black's Rook on eight is tied down and I
think whenever black pushes that a pawn
to A4 white can actually just keep the
double pawns as they are you can just
think about moving your B Pawn to B4
taking away that C5 Square tying down
that B5 pawn and one of White's black
pieces will have to defend that pawn for
a really long time you pointed out the
space and Robert uh David added to that
the attack on the a file I I think that
explains why White's the one who's
pushing in this
position I like everything you say feels
like there's a big hole rob it sorry I'm
zoned in on the C6 Square uh just we
need to highlight that one it looks like
a dream Outpost for any of White's
pieces but the problem is a knight can't
get there very easily because the pawns
cover the entry points but a rook can
but Al r FIA says Tanya your idea it's
pretty good let me go ahead and double
The Rook so I actually think that black
may have to play this move A4 even if
you don't want to because you end up
freezing your own Pawn structure it's
you're going to lose the a pawn
otherwise so A4 to my eyes looks
reasonable another move is Rook C8
there's an open file you should put your
Rook on it and the big question that I
have David is that if this a pawn is in
fact lost and I actually don't see an
easy way to keep it defended because
even after A4 Rook A1 comes to mind does
black have drawing chances chances to
equalize by playing arounded playing for
activity want to say yes uh for Jose
Martinez's sake but I think dropping a
pawn here unless something really
magical happens unless he somehow gets
the black Bishop into the game the Black
Knight on D7 into the game it's going to
be a real struggle um to seek
compensation you always need active
pieces and U maybe that black Bishop
comes in now that's one way to defend
that a pawn um it's a bit of
Journey a bit of a path around it takes
three moves essentially to reactivate
itself but in a block position maybe you
do have that luxury it definitely feels
like his back's against the wall and
Martinez he's great at kind of finding
resources when it looks like things are
going against him but uh yeah I do fear
just with the Simplicity of White's
moves the Simplicity of White's plans
that Tanya pointed out that uh even if
he finds some compensation it's going to
take him a bunch of time on the clock
and already we see him a minute down
maybe soon a porn down yeah I would take
FIA here all day
long the more I look at this position
the more I see the strength in these
doubled bonds uh right now he doesn't go
for the idea of Bishop B7 bishop d8 and
I think that's a really great defensive
resource you spotted David he's going
for the activity and that is classic
Jose Martinez he doesn't believe in
passive defense he's always trying for a
way where he can keep his pieces active
even if it comes at the cost of material
now the problem here is that even if
black was to step up firstly you can't
go Queen to C7 because that Queen needs
to stay connect to the B5 Pawn as well
actually don't see a way for the pawn to
stay alive on A5 uh which means you're
going to go down a pawn and now I'm just
wondering where is this activity that
Jose is looking for he goes a fork and
white just grab this take it with your
Pawn take it with the rook and to me it
just looks like an extra Pawn Robert it
is an extra Pawn but at least the queen
on B8 will stare down in open Line The
Rook on C8 is in a fully open file so
this is what Jose is relying on whether
it's going to pan out for him is a
different question question but at least
he is giving himself a clearer plan
because the path in front of his pieces
has now opened up so this Pawn can and
is captured this black queen can slide
up to B3 there's Rook C2 potentially to
follow in fact I didn't even draw the
blue arrow that was the engine telling
us that you he had to play Queen B3 it's
given an exclamation point it also was
the point of his Pawn sacrifice in this
manner so David I think that black we
can see clear counterplay but is it
enough would you feel comfortable at all
with the black
pieces I'd never feel comfortable
playing against ala fuja especially with
black he's a beast when he has white
he's beaten me in some of the biggest
games in my career when he has the white
pieces but uh yeah I think actually Jose
he's done the best of a bad job uh of a
bad position at least he's kind of
chosen the Lesser evil being a porn down
um I think he's just uh playing kind of
hustling here a bit but he's doing the
right thing you have to play for that
activity you cannot just suffer
passively and let your opponent slowly
at will at their own discretion outplay
you so yeah he's done a good job at
least the clock situation which I was a
bit worried about it's kind of turned in
his favor suddenly due to this active
play and against fua you have to fight
fire with fire or firea with firea and
yeah I think he's uh doing a good job
here but talking of being a porn down
maybe we zoom out to the other game just
for a quick update while FIA takes a
longer think um because it's also a PN
down situation for fed and that is bad
news not just in terms of the fact that
npom Nishi is objectively better but
white only needs a draw and Nishi here
with an a extra pawn it should be in the
bank
Tanya yeah I mean this end game just
looks like again it's all white play
Black is trying to Target the F5 Pawn
fed trying to attack both the A5 and the
F5 Pawn but F6 is weak U for Yan he can
actually go ahead and pick up one more
pawn and the thing is FV needs a win in
this position a draw is just not enough
even if if he manages to survive upon on
down he is out of the cherel Masters
where is he going to create his winning
chances here Robert where do you see how
do you see that even being a possibility
a hope here you have to rely on your dwn
I guess I know the answer to the
question is realistically Yan is not
going to lose this game but if it's
going to come from anywhere for feda he
does have a pass Pawn that can't easily
march on the board his Rook on B5 hits
the F5 Pawn hits that A5 Pawn as you
mentioned so white does have a few
things to fix F out but I'm looking at
this and I'm wondering why can't white
just continue snacking on pawns and
trading off more pieces because there
aren't so many pawns remaining in this
position I don't see winning chances for
black I'm trying to come up with
something but I even this the advantage
is given away but black needs to win not
draw so tough here fed have three
minutes on the clock and uh as we were
saying it's just a tough tough position
he does go passive with the black Bishop
to defend but look at this really classy
end game play really beautiful move
there I saw your reaction Robert just
locking Black's pawns on D squares that
is a fixed Target now it's not running
away anytime soon that black pawn the
white Bishop can slide at will back to
pick it off and then White's H porn
becomes a real monster maybe a potential
future Queen there exclamation mark for
good reason Robert that's a lovely move
yeah you are just cementing that pawn in
place fixing it on the color that your
Bishop is on so the black Bishop is a
passive piece is defending these loose
Pawns in the position sorry that's the
third loose pawn and white fixes that
pawn on H6 lovely decision I'm not
really worried at all for yand pishi it
does seem like he's just a few moves
away from winning so why don't we maybe
head back to our other game where there
is a little bit more tension and drama
because it's half to half they drew
their first game and in game two between
aliv zaa and Jose Martinez look at the
position now I Jose he's trying to
occupy the B file go after White's extra
Pawn it's not like white has the
clearest plan in the world it is black
to move but David why can't you just
grab this Pawn on B2 now I don't see any
reason not to a porn is a porn as you
mentioned earlier in another game I hate
being pawns down for no reason so why
not restore the balance um that's one
load off the mind I guess white will
either trade off or maybe even go active
with the White Queen uh Queen to C7 but
then it becomes a bit more random I
don't see any exact specific threats for
white it looks nice and pretty kind of
lined up on the seventh rank with the
White Queen and Rook
but next where do you go next um I don't
reason to pause I guess Jose doesn't
need to rush that pawn might be
available next move um really kind of
tense tense position but evaluation bar
here Tanya I feel it's
deceptive I'm looking at that extra Pawn
to neutralize that you have to pick it
up I really like the idea of keeping the
queens and not shading it off Queen to
C7 the other move that comes to mind is
even Queen to C6 it can be really scary
handling that he is touching the two and
a half minute Mark both players are
under three minutes uh once the queen
lands on the sixth of the seventh rank
there are big threats on the board Queen
C6 would threaten Rook takes Knight on
D7 and he does go to capture the B2 pawn
and we see this first question how do
you parry this big threat I don't
believe you can really move that Knight
anywhere because if you do that then
there are I ideas against the F7 Pawn if
you were to go Knight to C5 or Knight to
B6 then you move Queen C7 really comes
uh with a big double attack on that F7
pawn and also the Rook but look at this
passive defense it's given a miss that
means the knight jump probably was
better but as you said Tanya very
difficult to move the Knight when the F7
Pawn was in The Rook sights but David to
your point from earlier I don't see how
white crashes through you can make all
sorts of little improvements moves King
H2 is a nice one making sure there's no
check on the first rank over here but
let's say black gets passive Queen to B8
I'm going to try to play Rook C8 to kick
your queen out of there or try to trade
Queens so David where are the inroads
from Ali raz's perspective he's got more
space he's got more control but you need
to actually Target and take something at
some point it's not going to be easy uh
I still think from a human point of view
both players probably assume White's
slightly better but they won't assume
it's a big advantage and um Robert you
mentioned the weaknesses there aren't
many actually in Black's Camp uh it must
just be the D6 pawn and that is a
backward Pawn it's only defended by
Black's passive Bishop someday
eventually it might take time White's
Knight is going to come back via D2 over
to C4 H just to sit and pressure that
pawn for good first there's a hit on the
White Queen so the White Queen needs to
move uh where do you Retreat her I don't
know if you can step forward um Queen to
C7 now might just run into a hit with uh
moves like Rook to D7 maybe you step
back uh Queen to A4 Queen to C4 I think
you just need to maneuver improve I Want
To Praise Fu's King to H2 move though
that shows he's played a bunch of Blitz
and bullet in his life you never want to
allow a check when your clock is ticking
down but uh yeah it's going to be a long
long grind it's going to take a while to
maneuver and only then start to set up
the tactics for white David alza doesn't
step back what are the chances of him
going Queen to a the move looks crazy
and maybe it's too much cuz you're
lining your queen against The Rook but I
don't see an IM imediate big knight jump
Queen a is that a possibility wow I was
not looking in that direction at all
David I I know you you're like wait
that's a legal Square to go to yeah
that's that's a really cool move I think
black may be forced to bring the Rook up
well now definitely Rook D7 but even
after queen8 bringing the Rook to the
seventh rank this queen on B2 it's
really doing excellent work covering so
many squares and pieces but now that the
Rooks are getting traded off and okay
this is Black's only move according to
the engines but it also is very natural
and replacing the Rook with the Knight
afterwards once again I keep asking this
question mainly to myself but also out
loud how is white going to make progress
from there the D6 Pawn is not easy to
get to especially because E4 and F2 and
White's Camp need to be
defended we saw a shake of the head as
well from Jose Martinez before he traded
off those Rooks but if I were him I
would be breathing a sigh of relief uh
he essentially traded off his own bad
Rook for White's very strong Rook uh it
must just be based on a very direct
attempt attempt at Victory here fora
he's going in for the kill with the
white knight but the White Knight is not
jumping any further there is a check you
can check but the black king just moves
and look at this the blue arrow the
computer says White's best move is to
admit defeat and go back just admit that
your last move was mistaken and uh there
simply a hit on your E4 Pawn so he might
have to find this Robert is it just me
or is momentum changing things are
turning on bord and clock momentum is
changing so it is The Other Board I'm
going have to quickly bring up this one
I cannot believe what I'm seeing over
here fed is winning because Checkmate in
one is threatened white stole the H Pawn
that's the good news but black has this
D Pawn that is quicker and checkm and
one is threatened I'm inan just utter
disbelief how in the world did this go
wrong for Yan pami he can't believe it
fedos say wi Tanya
what whoa Yana Boni resigns FV wins the
game comes back in the match takes it
into Armageddon a game that we had
written off as one that Yan she can
never lose Rook to G3 check would have
been a massive one forcing King to H4
and how do you fight it because you're
not only fighting this check you're
fighting the D Pawn as well D3 D2 D1 is
just queening you can't do anything
about it and he just gives up and yet
with a shake of his head he can't
believe it either
David and I just went back to check uh
two moves ago Yan was still still
winning it was self-inflicted he pushed
his own Pawn to F4 he blocked in his own
Bishop he pretty much trapped his own
white king yeah we're showing this now
Robert as we see Yan kind of smiling and
kind of laughing at what he did Pawn to
F4 question mark he's trapped his own
King walked into a mating n and after
the next move Rook to E3 brilliant fine
from FV he didn't realize until it was
too late npom nesi taking that pawn on
H6 and after Bishop to E1 as Robert
pointed out Rook G3 is a killer threat
the pawn is rolling game over it went
from winning to losing in two moves
chess is brutal rapid chess is so
unforgiving what a finish to that game
and I think when you're much better for
most of the game your opponent just kind
of flailing and uh doing random things
you just assume that nothing's going to
work but fedos have never stopped
calculating he's kind of like the
Undertaker you know he's coming back
from the dead against Magnus Carlson and
now against yand pomi and as we dive
back into this game between fuja and
Jose Martinez well the same problems
persist for black there's this decent
six Pawn that's targeted a number of
times but I just don't think white has
enough Firepower to keep attacking it
Tanya look at the clock Jose down now
under at 13
seconds W he's touching that 10c Mark he
makes the move he can only Shuffle
around with the King and stay passive
keep those pawns defended there isn't
much activity to fight for but he's
taking control of White's King squar not
allowing White's King an entry point
trying to trade off as many pawns as
possible and both players playing on
seconds right now it's
still where is the winning chance is
white going to March all the way from
the queen side over with his King David
possibly I think the simple plan now is
there is a threat Knight to B5 he's
defended his Central points with the
white king and the other three of his
army are going to go for that backward
Pawn the black D6 Pawn but hose is
fighting so tenaciously he's trying to
use his own Knight to go for the white
king some checks some hits on the white
pawns but look at this all of white
pieces this is the picture of teamwork
three of them ganging up on one Soul
weakness missed opportunity apparently
according to the computer but looks very
logical to me and again the white king
defending the rest of the pieces
attacking and a piece sacrifice
desperation from jfam here he's going to
get two white pawns but White's going to
be left with one key remaining Pawn this
one's over Robert yes this was a nice
retreating move as well from fuja he
secured extra material now he stopped
his knight from coming to F4 it goes
there anyway but this is a winning end
game at this stage for white D5 is gone
you can't actually defend the pawn H4
comes next and as long as you keep your
last Pawn do not allow this to get two
knights and a king versus a bear King
because that is the draw in fact fuja
wins by resignation because he knows
that Jose's not gonna get that H3 Pawn
fua he survives Jose Martinez his time
in the ches Masters is done but what a
run he had but it does come to an end
Jose Martinez is eliminated from the
chessel Masters Ali Resa fuja continues
his run I've got to say that last
position and that game too he did it
convincingly and these are our score
lines it's not over in the losers
quarterfinals because we've got a big
armagedon coming up as Vladimir FV does
score a win in the second game a
miraculous win a miraculous save and to
me Robert David it is so reminiscent of
what happened in the fasy of Maxim VRA
match up Maxim was completely winning in
that armagen against F but just a last
minute slip just so becoming a little
casual at the very end and it cost him a
big win in that matchup uh this one goes
into Armageddon what are we expecting
has the momentum shifted psychologically
as well I think it definitely has I mean
for Vladimir fedos he earned his way
through but David take us through how
this went so wrong for Yan I just wanted
to go through a slow action replay of
what happened Yan na ponesi on the brink
of winning his match pretty much played
a perfect game up to here it looks like
white is winning it's all due to the
weakness of this Pawn the weakness of
the F6 Pawn as well but fed this is a
tip for everyone at home keep fighting
keep looking for tricks for resources
first this bishop is offside doing
nothing he brought it into the game via
D2 to protect this pawn and this
provoked the mistake here Yan with a
calmer mind a cooler mind he would have
simply gone for the other weakness the
F6 Pawn maybe even he could have just
pinned this bishop with a big Advantage
a winning position but but always look
out for your king even deep into the end
game Pawn to F4 as Robert highlighted
earlier was the mistake not just a
mistake but a pair of mistakes after
Rook to E3 a big big threat here and
unfortunately after Bishop takes Pawn
Yan still oblivious now the threat
landed on the board and uh just to show
what could have happened if for example
White had moved the bishop again
clearing the path for this Pawn this
would have been a nasty check the white
king now forced to move and a beautiful
discovered check hitting the white king
winning the white Rook on on the next
turn so always watch out for your king
Never Take Your Eye Off the ball and
don't forget the opponent Yan
unfortunately there just uh yeah
relaxing one move too early and now has
to pay that price with an
Armageddon he needs to do it all over
again against Vladimir FV in their rapid
match two big wins by the black pieces
in the bids how low are the players
going to go to try and get black we will
be back with the big armagon and the
bits do not go
[Music]
anywhere
but the goal is get you to a comfortable
spot in those first 10 opening moves and
just have you hit in that
guas That's all folks thanks so much for
checking out my E4 course here on chess
I do hope you
[Music]
enjoy I got introduced to chess because
uh my family
is obviously both my mom and dad's side
is from uh former Soviet Union uh and
it's kind of part of the culture there
so I was playing with my grandfather
when I was about five and I I I think
What attracted me when I was younger is
I just got the game I got the game
probably on the level how most modern
day Grandmasters got the game I could
see something once and I could just go
demolish adults kids uh and and for most
talented players that's how it is for a
long time they just obsess over the
[Music]
game I hate to compare it to Art but in
many ways it is I find it fascinating
every day I can teach myself something
played it for 20 years and there's still
so much I don't know I can play Blitz
Games and I can make Masterpiece or
chaos with white with black what a time
to be alive you know because I still
have insecure chess teacher Syndrome
from 2019 when I was just going to
private lessons and nobody knew who I
was and I still remember those days and
like I very easily just think about them
and I I'm not I'm completely the same
guy I just happen to do it on camera
now last World Championship I was
looking at five streams at the same time
like getting all the information trying
to understand the position more uh like
I keeping in mind what I'm going to say
in the recap a couple hours later who
who said what that's the stuff that that
I really get excited by just knowing
that it was it was a good recording it
was funny it was I presented everything
I want to present uh that stuff I guess
is like a cycle that that gets me more
energy I really enjoy making a high
quality piece of content it is very
natural for me uh to do the presenting
like I'm not fake at all I think that's
one of the reasons I can I can stream
and stay same but like sometimes even
I'm exhausted and after I record a video
I have more energy which doesn't make
[Music]
sense I feel good about the current
career I I don't spend a huge amount of
time being uh introspective about the
current career I I'm just working as
hard as
possible with me it's just me and the
camera which which is even I don't know
I would even argue it's more weird that
it's just me in a room from 2020 until
now I'm still just some dude who likes
to talk about Chess and I just so happen
to do it in a uh in an exciting way for
a lot of people and obviously okay my
confidence has grown in presenting and
knowing that what I put out will get
watched which is you don't have that
guarantee when you start it's very nice
and it's not something I I take uh
lightly but at the end of the day if you
really break it down and just the dude
who talks about
Chess
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
another
video I've taken an approach in this
course where I will happily enter the
main lines of certain openings for the
first five or 10 ms before deviating
into something that's aggressive
interesting uh and will
[Music]
definitely
take
[Music]
exra
oh
and we are going to have the Armageddon
between these two friends well there's
no friendship going into the next one as
it will be all about that clock and who
gets the winning bid and we've got the
bids with
us look at that it is Vladimir fos who
wins the bit 7 minutes 35 seconds y
bidding 8 minutes he didn't go that low
what do you make of this bid Robert
Vladimir P starts with the black pieces
well Yan pishi has shown a tendency to
prefer the white pieces in armagen
yesterday against Maxim Vash lra he also
had white but while he won the game it
wasn't pretty he was in fact losing
before Maxine brought his King in too
far so I don't know if I love the bid I
think fedos is going to be happy taking
black H yesterday uh he had an
experience against Magnus Carson when he
had the white piece there a lot of
pressure there now things have changed
up we see the caroan defense black is
temporarily sacrific to porn but will'll
win that back on this turn and fed this
is one of his favorite openings with
white with black one of his highest
score openings now however a hit against
a weak spot on G7 don't bring your queen
out too early folks unless you're a
Grandmaster and you know when to get
away with it White Queen doing uh some
really annoying work there and now after
creating weakness it's time to get
castled um Robert I've got to say the
time Advantage having an extra couple of
minutes in what is likely to be a
complicated middle game now it surely
will stand the pishy in good stad yeah
there's something about this opening
that I don't like even if you give me a
ton of time from the black side look at
all these holes in the dark squares and
this bishop on C5 well if it gets back
to G7 maybe I feel a little bit better
but still not so fantastic so I
that wasn't me I thought I misclicked he
actually just brought his Bishop back to
fa Tanya that is one of the wildest
predictions I've had that's insane it
reminds me of your prediction of Bishop
to C7 I mean how did that even happen I
still think about it when it was a one
move lunder and I think you dropped it
and Magnus dropped it and right now
Bishop to F another bishop move robed
the prophet strikes again the bishop
does land on G7 but I think you can
explain this one the dark Square
weakness that you pointing out for
Black's King to be safe on the king side
it's so critical for black to have that
fan
Bishop I think we should rename you
Robert fed Robert Sayes because uh yeah
it's just you and you and Vladimir here
you're so in sync and uh the downside I
guess behind this bishop maneuver is it
costs a lot of time look how many white
pieces are out there pouring forward
already White's Queen all the minor
pieces the white rook in in the center
E1 yes the p structure is locked blocked
for now but if things open up white is
by far the more ready to pounce uh so
fed say of living life on the edge uh
Robert he's played your maneuver he's
now attacking the white E5 Pawn do you
see him unraveling untangling from this
position I think he's doing a good job
thus far because he's forcing Yan to
slow down and now we see that the
difference of clock is 2 minutes so I
think from that perspective fed has to
be happy but he hasn't developed any of
his pieces if I'm y pomi I don't want to
give up this Central Pawn maybe there
are some tactics available to White that
allow you to give up E5 because the
black king remains in the center but I
probably would just drop my Bishop back
to F4 I know I put my Bishop on G5 a
turn ago but I want to keep this Pawn on
E5 and he does it in a different way
with Queen to G3 I like that as well so
atan I would say from a strategic Point
White's doing well but I think fedos
have he maybe in this comfort zone of
this Wy type of opening where he feels
at home he's going to feel more at home
once that knight from G8 can come out
and the only parts that I see is from E7
he does hit the bishop right now so
forcing Yan to take a decision you've
got to fall back with that bishop and
then I'm expecting fedf to continue with
his development Knight to E7 maybe
someday it will land on F5 but you've
got to be careful you've got to watch
out before you make that move go Knight
E7 get your king to safety put that
Bishop on D7 start advancing the B Pawn
and it does look like things have
started
uh looking slightly more playable for
black more space for white though that
said David Bishop falls back to F4 do
you think that Yan should be happier out
of the opening outcome right
now Yan would not complain if you
offered him this position with an extra
minute on his clock beforehand but uh
there is a bit of pressure now long-term
black has a lot of potential black is
rock solid black has no real weaknesses
if pieces start to disappear if Knights
Bishops Queens get traded off actually
if anyone's better it's going to be
black due to having two Central pawns
white only having one in the center
white E5 Pawn looks very strong now but
could become a weakness uh so time is
very much of the essence in Armageddon
as always but also on the board Pawn A3
might look like a timid move but watch
out if black ever has the courage to
Castle quein side white will oh he's
setting it up now with Bishop D7 white
will throw pawns forward Pawn to B4 Pawn
to B5 and explode that flank so really
really Cy stuff right now I think Yan
needs to act quickly Pawn to H4 he's
kind of bluffing now he's playing on
both sides of the board with pawns he's
asking where the black king is going to
go and no this isn't a mous either of it
get to f8 this is a standard plan when
your kingside is under attack that what
leaves your Rook as a defensive piece
and white can't team up on it but I love
the move from Yan Naomi Knight D1 Knight
E3 Knight G4 and the H6 pawn and the F6
Square are accessible from the Knight so
this Knight is doing a bit of dancing
it's going on a
a real adventure and black says I'm not
even going to think about your night
getting there Tanya I have to say I like
this change in Pawn structure for black
because now the position isn't as
one-sided and I think this last move
really explains that King s step it
wasn't a mouse SL it was a move with the
plan the king from F defended that
Bishop in G7 so allowing fedf to go
Knight to F5 tradeoff having double
pawns but opening up the G line for
counter play so again a double- EDG game
but let's remind every one that fetos
needs only a draw it's so important for
him to keep the clock under control and
to not get the position super messy
because for Yan he has to go all out
he's the one who's in a must-win game
right now so this kind of complication
this kind of a double situation does it
seem to favor Yan more than
fev especially after these last couple
of moves Yan suddenly he's played two or
three quick instant replies and look at
the white porns he's gained all the
space on the center on the queen side
yes this last move given a question mark
But White Knight has the most beautiful
perch you'll ever see an outpost on D4
um so Yan I think he's got enough pieces
enough uh control here to guarantee a
long game and with two extra minutes on
the clock in Armageddon no increment
that could be decisive I would love to
play two moves in a row if I could with
white I was going to say Knight D4 and
pawn to H5 just to stop any Knight G6
ideas and um yeah it just feels like Yan
he's in his element right now it's not
winning Advantage it's not even maybe a
significant Advantage but um f 4 minutes
on the clock it's not going to be easy
at all Robert do you think uh wow King
to G8 first of all with the blue arrow
there do you think that's natural I was
going to say do you think fed is
comfortable with his position oh clearly
King to G8 wasn't that natural because
he brings his Rook to G8 and how could
you blame him bringing his Rook to an
open line where the enemy Queen is but
this bishop on G7 can't move so
tactically speaking this isn't going to
work out for black you don't want to
drop this H6 Pawn so this position is
difficult for both sides the bishop on
A4 that is a nasty piece because you
can't bring a rook to D1 you can't march
your pawns forward on B4 and C5 so I
think both sides have things to be happy
about I see the engine evaluation off
the side I don't care about that I both
players are recognizing that it's not
easy to break through so Tanya and look
at white getting the queen out the way
what is the actual plan for either side
frankly we're going to wait on watch
that being played out I think there are
two ideas black can perhaps aim at
trying to trade off that very strong
Knight on D4 eventually come with his
own Knight to C6 trying to exchange as
many pieces as possible but that said
the current position with the number of
pieces on the board with both players
well fedy have under five minutes and
Yan pami touching the five minute Mark
and what we have in front of us I think
we're in for a wild time scramble in
this one and it is going to come into
who's faster on the mouse who's got that
extra seconds on the clock I'm expecting
some peace trades to happen and he does
it Knight C6 on the board rob it a good
decision by fed it is a good decision
and he needs to control those light
squares and when it's a Clos position
Knights are often Superior to Bishop so
that's why there's one Knight on D4
perhaps a second Knight can replace it
because the Knight appears over the
block position whereas Bishops if there
was a bishop on D4 instead it would
stare into its own Pawn so that's why
these Knights are looking so promising
and that is why T recommended the trade
of these pieces so David if these kn
I maybe not say if when these kns come
off the board do you see how to further
make progress because it looks like a
completely blockaded
position it's tough It's Not Easy and um
therefore kind of with the lack of
obvious plans I'm inclined to agree with
tan and say it's going to be a time
scramble pretty much guaranteed and at
some point you just need to make moves
even if you're not kind of progressing
advancing your position not kind of
making inroads into uh kind of Black's
camp for example if you're yandi King H2
a great move for example you just tease
your opponent bring that Rook to G1
pretend you're going to play G4 maybe
you do play Pawn to G4 uh either way
you've got extra time on the clock and
there we go he's now attacking and uh
it's far easier to attack as we all know
than it is to defend with that clock
ticking down so under four minutes now
fed big decision does he have to take on
G4 allow the White Knight closer to that
black king the black king is almost
actually in a mating net as it is uh no
real Escape squares
presses the chaos button instead Pawn to
F6 Robert clock board it all just
exploded in this last couple of moves it
certainly has and if G takes F5 is the
only move to leave white with the
advantage this position is much trickier
than the evaluation bar would let us
believe now Yan this was a natural move
for him if this Pawn takes on E5 yes it
looks like a fork as G takes F received
an exclamation point but there's a queen
on F3 there's a king on f8 you don't
want to see all the pieces get out the
way so there will be tactics that allow
white not just to save the material but
win some material so in this position I
think if you're Vladimir you just slide
your queen on over to F7 it's going to
be a bad position but at least the white
king doesn't feel that safe Tanya we
could see the makings of a latter
checkmate with a rook on the G file and
if this queen somehow some way can get
to a square like
H4 whoa and I'm just looking at the
decision that F have has just taken and
I was wondering is this even possible
because I thought that W could actually
push the E Pawn and create play against
the double pawns but he goes for a more
direct idea doesn't sacrifice the pawn
opens up the bishop but the downside of
doing it this way Robert to me is that
black gets play as well grabbing on F6
now that fia's Bishop is active I think
that gives black some hope in this
position I was expecting E6 at that
moment yeah that would have been a nice
move instead of capturing and David now
that you know we're here we can revisit
uh that moment a little bit later this
Knight on E3 is pinned and this white
King on H2 if this black king slinks to
the corner whose King do you think is
actually
safer I would love to be fed suddenly
out of the blue not just because
objectively maybe he's got more chances
now but um it's just pure lack of
control it's in IR rational position
Nomi has no idea what's going on we I
kind of uh have to calculate here just
to try and figure out who's better but
uh as you say if the black queen
activates if the black Rook on E8 gets
one more move comes down to
E4 I really fear for the white king the
black king at least blacks it easy
that's all you want in a Time scramble
Knight takes Pawn now check forcing the
black king into the corner and yeah that
white king look at the air around it
look at all the possible checkmating
patterns there's so many of them um I
agree Robert the evaluation bar still
favors white but this has been turning
and uh if momentum continues as it is I
think fedf he's got great chances now um
suddenly the narrow path that white has
to tread it's only getting narrower and
narrower every single move what do you
even play here with white your Rook is
hanging in the center Nishi I wouldn't
be surprised if he tanks now and uh kind
of slips up it's so easy to go wrong wow
this position has turned completely
ananya we've talked about FV yesterday
against Magnus Carlson it looked like he
was on his way down to the losers
bracket and he won a game on time then
in Armageddon he had the upper hand he
couldn't find the Tactical sequence
Magnus was able to escape with the match
Victory and here it looked like
everything was going wrong for Vladimir
and now his King has scurried on over to
the corner Vladimir is actually the one
ahead on time let's not forget we're not
getting these two seconds of increment
with every turn Jan is in serious time
trouble now this is Armageddon Yan has
to win this game he's got the white
pastes he's got no increment he's Below
on the clock it's his Rooks that are
hanging right now Yan does look calm but
I don't think he's got to he's going to
be that calm on the inside the first big
question is what is his next move I
would think that he would just trade on
E8 immediately right my Rook on D4 is
hanging my Rook on E1 is hanging what is
he thinking about right now what are the
other moves is Rook E4 Rook E4 is not
even possible what am I saying I mean
what do you even play here there's no
easy moves that's the problem but he's
got to just choose something for better
or worse he's got to trade Rooks as you
say Tanya maybe leave that white Rook on
D4 and wow he was calculating this but
look at the evaluation bar we said it so
easy to go wrong double question mark
move I'm wondering what he has in store
if the black Dart Square Bishop just
takes that white Rook a free piece in
the center he's got to go for checkmate
now against the black king but maybe
there isn't one he's now down a minute
on the clock I'm thinking again Robert
he's miscalculated he's me missed
something here and look at this the blue
arrow it strikes Queen takes F7 a queen
sacrifice because the Rook on E1 is
loose at the end and black will have two
Rooks and a bishop and an attack against
the white king so this is going to be
too much material in Black's favor FV
look at him he is locked in and he
senses the moment for yand pomi it's a
bad sign when you give away a rook and
then you still think afterwards his time
in the Chess Masters could come to an
end in the next few moves but I think
Robert it's critical for FV to play this
move because if you were to move up with
your king which he does can't white give
a check on D3 trade on E8 and pick up
the bishop on
D4 oh did you did you see Nomi lean back
with surprise there he look he feels
that he's got a second life now and he
has he has to go for that variation that
you mentioned Tanya it's strictly forced
but more importantly he needs to move
one minute left it's still chaotic we're
miles away from a decision on this game
from the climax he needs to move one
minute it's bullet chess now he's living
life on the
edge about flagging David this is going
to be about flagging and it's game on
right now he goes for this gives a
check Rook E4 the blue arrows here it's
the only move it it makes sense to keep
the bishop defended if you think you're
going to attack a knight Queen G6 would
be checkm he walked into a m he walked
into a mating
net my gosh now he's only got one legal
move he has to block and White's just
motoring forward White's going to
Checkmate or win the black queen the
black Bishop is overworked overloaded
he's got a flag Nomi now only chance
he's down a queen for rook and Bishop
he's lost oh that was a tragic
turnaround but I will say there are
still chances for black thanks to this
Pawn on D4 it's not going to be you know
an easy win for white whose own King is
in trouble Tanya we have seen crazier
things happen than a black win in this
game I completely agree with you and for
yanami he's got to wrap it up with just
40 seconds no increment the two Bishops
Super Active F3 Pawn always Under Fire
look at that evalar already a mistake by
Yan can black actually just capture on
F3
now maybe he can he's considering it he
can win back the White Queen immediately
but first he grabs another pawn and
white gives a check another check but
all of the white pawns are dropping a
draw is good enough for black to
progress here and you cannot deliver
checkmate with a queen alone so he's
using his Bishop but he's dropping all
his pawns here
Robert yeah you can just keep trading
pieces and in fact I think black will
have a fortress at the end you put your
Rook on the seventh rank or actually why
not this configuration these pieces are
Untouchable here everything protects
something else and if this Rook gets to
D7 I mean how do you expect to win this
game with a rook behind the pass P what
a defense from better say it
unbelievable oh he
me King H6 Queen to E8 is the Checkmate
Y is one move away from winning this
there's no way to fight it Rook E7 runs
into Queen F6 and you pick up the
Rook over so quickly so
suddenly just going to win the black
Rook now and nothing to be done it's all
about flagging 23 seconds look at the
speed they're going to show they're
going to display but white has an extra
Queen surely this is over now will we
see another comeback no more pre moves
Naomi he's got this in the bank he's win
thing about Jana pal she's also a great
bullet player and this one I mean now
it's two Queens on the board it's done
oh my gosh and Vladimir fed have so
close yet so far
Andi throwing his hands in the air
unbelievable Armageddon oh my God
wow I don't have the words I really
don't have the words for what we just
saw and you know fedos his lights were
flickering but they've completely dimmed
his tournament is done with in the Chess
Masters he's been a wrecking ball of
sorts he took down Aliva fuja he gave
Magnus every bit of a fight and against
yand pishi just when he had everything
under control He Slipped the players I
believe they're talking to one another
They Know Each Other Well fedos even
though he's bowed out of the competition
he has proven that he is a force and we
have seen him so many times in the last
season win division 2 the big fish and
no doubt will'll be back with some big
games in the Champions Chester what an
Armageddon we saw the players discuss
the moves out in the end because it was
that crazy David I think this was one of
the most exciting ends to a match that
we've seen one of the most fascinating
Armageddon take us through the big
moments this was incredible so many
highlights from that Armageddon alone
but I just wanted to show the final
mistake where it all slipped away from
fed's grasp and it was here we were just
praising him for being the comeback King
for defending a really difficult
position and saving it with black a draw
being enough with Armageddon to progress
but one slip was all it took here the
black porn is very strong but you can
just leave it abandon it if you keep
your formation for example like this
King to G7 and uh just kind of keep your
Rook just maintain it on the f file
there's no way forward for white The
Rook the bishop the king they'll protect
each other Cur up into a ball this is
the definition of a fortress instead
such bad luck for fed he played Rook to
D7 in this position he broke the
formation and allowed the white king
forward this was a really accurate check
the only winning move from yand pomi and
as we know kings in the corner are
susceptible to mating patterns King to
H6 exclamation mark from Nomi spotting
his only opportunity because there are
no checks black cannot defend this is a
deadly Checkmate throw on the back rank
Queen to F6 is also a threat and at what
happened in the game Rook to C7
defending this Square allowed a check
another check and because the Rooks
undefended it was simply game over
things turn so quickly in Armageddon
chess it was a time scramble ultimately
neishi was the one to
Triumph unbelievable moral of the story
keep your pawns closed but keep your
Rooks even closer I mean what was that
what a turn around Yana she seconds away
from being eliminated and then just
makes a big comeback but you make your
own luck on the chess board you make
your own resources and he kept going and
that's what we saw it's not over till
it's over and today it's not over
because we've got a big big winers final
coming up as well Robert I mean so many
highlights as well from uh from our
losers
bracket besides the Armageddon what else
comes to your mind I I forgot and
everything that else that happened
before this yeah let's be honest the Ala
win over Jose Martinez feels like a
lifetime ago it all is about that last
game and Yan naami the way he stood in
there he found his last chance and a bit
of a time crunch that is impressive he's
done it a multiple occasions now and as
you said you sort of make your own luck
they say better lucky than good I say
best great and lucky and that way is
what Yan palish she is he survives he
stays alive the ches
Masters we've had so much action guys
but remember the main course is still to
come that was just the appetizer we have
Magnus Carlson entering the frey against
Dennis lazic and we cannot wait but just
before we go on a break uh I wanted to
mention that Opera and chess.com have
collaborated on the internet browser for
chess enthusiasts the world's first
chess browser has chess integrated right
into the sidebar so you're only ever one
click away from a quick game of Blitz or
a puzzle while you work you can even pin
the sidebar panel open so that you can
carry on read ing watching or browsing
with one eye on the board while your
opponent plots their next move this is
available for Windows Mac and Androids
use exclamation point chess browser in
the chat now to download Opera for free
take it for a test ride we'll see you
soon we are going to see you very very
soon but use this time to download that
Opera browser get a bullet in because
you're going to need all that action for
the action that is coming up as we head
into the big winners final we'll be back
with the 17-year-old Dennis lavic taking
on world number one Magnus
[Music]
Carlson
welcome to a world where each game
writes a new story with endless
possibilities and surprising twists we
present the next big new tournament the
freestyle chess goat challenge at the
Forefront of this epic chess spectacle
is none other than Magnus Carlson the
former world champion facing his first
duel with the reigning world champion
ding Len since his title victory in
addition to this top duel Carlson has
selected six other top Challengers to
make the tournament especially
exciting be sure to watch all the games
on the live stream at chess.com and on
our freestyle dest
website from February 9th to 16 2024 at
the first freestyle chess goat challenge
at the luxurious weisson House Resort
experience the thrill and fascination of
Chess in a completely new
[Music]
light our once magnificent Kingdom of
Chess lays now in ruins our King slain
but some say that a new ruler will come
and restore the realm to its former
glory solve puzzles fight epic battles
and earn gold swords and Scrolls full of
Chess wisdom on your way to reclaiming
the throne download the app today and
this month only face off against your
favorite Kingdom character Bots only on
chess.com
I am deeply offended by your poor eats
porn Rule I think that sort of thing is
cannibalism and Must Be Stopped let's
have a zoom discussion about
it and he includes the zoom link I love
can we can we open that now is he there
that'd be great I love the tone of that
like it's it's cannibalism let's have a
zoom discussion about it here's a l like
that is so good I was sure that was
going to be an enant ticket you know
yeah right up tell cannibalism yeah I
thought you we we were we were ready for
ersan he took us down a deep dark world
of cannibalism and here we are and by
the way I hope he's not waiting for us
on Zoom I wasn't even swearing in a mean
way I'm Australian it's how we
talk crunky WABE walking about I'm
actually with him on that have you ever
talked to an Australian they drop an F
bomb like literally every other word and
I think you know one of the things we've
actually are working on now is that
friend chats have a different filter uh
so that if you're playing a friend you
know you can actually have engage in
some fun trash talking uh so that is
that is something we realistically are
are looking at because people deserve
that experience if they want Sean McCoy
bringing the knowledge didn't even know
that was a feature I love
it
a
[Music]
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walks right into and they
know it they know it turn your boards
909 952 made a big mistake oh and the
bar's going up this is an absolute Gem
of a game Wesley saw has done it he's
going for the attack but he's walked
into Checkmate black can play Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
my God what an arm we
getting welcome back everyone we hope
you've recovered from the absolutely
insane Armageddon Legend has it that
Yana pomi and fosf are still analyzing
what we just witnessed that was one of
the most entertaining games I've seen on
the tour what a fight to the end but at
the end of it all Yi goes through fedos
gets knocked out for the action is on
because now we're off to the winnner
final guys we've got 17-year-old Dennis
lazovic taking on Magnus Carlson Magnus
a big big favorite Robert what are you
expecting from Dennis in this one I'm
expecting more of the same solid play
from Dennis the Menace he has done
extraordinarily well to this point in
the chville Masters in the placement he
took down hiar Nakamura and anise girri
then he beat Maxim vagra and yesterday
it was Jose Martinez his latest victim
so Magnus Carlson he is the best player
in the world of Chess has been for the
last decade but why not you know you
have to rise to the occasion he's just a
teenager Dennis lazic he's proven that
he has what it takes to stick with the
best of them and meanwhile Magnus on his
part has eliminated Wesley saw and
Vladimir fed of knocking both of them
well not eliminated but knocking both of
them in the losers bracket with some big
wins it's going to be a big fight David
what are your expectations from this
finals well it's h hard to look past
Magnus Carlson the world number one the
Champions chest Tor reigning uh winner
and uh I think he will bring his aame we
heard yesterday in the interview how
seriously Magnus is taking his young
opponent yes Dennis lazic is in the form
of his life but this is going to be a
whole different challenge so Magnus if
he can start fast if he has been taking
it as seriously uh as he said he would
then I think he is still the massive
massive favorite then again we all love
an underdog so laic let's hope that he
is able to at least hang in there the
first couple of games if he does he will
gain in confidence as well um I just
wait for the games to get started uh
expect the unexpected as we always say
on the
tour Dennis lazic has been making waves
in online chess he impressed us all in
the Champions chess store season 23 made
it to Toronto had a great performance
there held his own in many many games we
saw him in the world rapid and Blitz as
well playing with the very best just
some fantastic results there and then
this event it's been the event of his
career so far it almost feels like and
now the biggest hurdle he's playing the
boss fight now plays against Magnus
Dennis is ready to go Robert what are
the opening expectations from this one
solid openings from Dennis and who knows
from Magnus Carlson because nobody knows
what he's going to try out on a given
day sometimes he moves his Rook pawns on
the first turn so for Dennis he has been
a rising star for a while now and the
star is shining bright he is Dennis the
Conqueror look at the names of the
players he has taken down on his path
towards the Winner's final Hikaru
Nakamura he needs no introduction anise
giri well that guy's pretty darn good at
chess too Maxim vashir lra so good that
he just goes by the three initials there
and is a former World Blitz Champion
Jose Martinez he may be world number 57
according to f rid ratings but he's much
stronger than that just doesn't play
over the board all that much and here
well this is the best player on the
planet Magnus Carlson I am stoked to see
these two go out it because when they
went head-to-head over the board in
Toronto as the first moves are underway
Dennis La was a few careful moves away
from making a draw in that first game
but ultimately it was Magnus who came
out on
top Magnus starts with the white pieces
uh Dennis is so strong with white
himself so Magnus will see this as a
chance to strike and he starts with the
English opening but already a pause here
um this is a bit of a surprising pause
from Magnus surely he's going to bring
out the other white knight or he's going
to push a pawn he's had this position
countless times before but Dennis is
well prepared already Magnus in the tank
for 30 seconds um Tanya the English
opening really part of magnus's Arsenal
but why is he thinking what is he
thinking about at this early stage I'm
as surprised as you are and while Magnus
thinks let's remind everyone the switch
up the losers bracket is a best of two
the Winner's bracket is the best of four
this is the first game Magnus perhaps
just trying to think about what kind of
opening structure he wants now to my
knowledge David D3 is not the most
topical move very often white goes
Knight F3 wants to strike in the center
with D4 Magnus took his time is this
what he calls the anti- young player
chess I would say so uh just taking the
opponent out of the book giving them a
lot of choice giving them strategic
questions um like you say it's not one
of the main moves um actually I'm going
to eat my words this is the English
opening this is the Sicilian Defense
just with colors reversed and white has
an extra Tempo having started the game
first so um yeah Magnus he's hoping that
Dennis who isn't a one E4 player who
doesn't play Sicilians on the opposite
side he's hoping he's a bit
uncomfortable so black has gone for what
we would call an open Sicilian here it's
just kind of trading off Pawns in the
center White's going for what we would
call the Sicilian Dragon setup with the
beautiful Bishop on G2 and uh the game
will now proceed very very quickly look
at that Bishop a real sniper so many
Targets on that diagonal but Dennis has
reacted almost instantly since this
small surprise um I've got to say Rober
really impressive speed and Confidence
from the youngster impressive from
Dennis surprising from Magnus I'm not
sure what he's thinking about on each
and every turn uh this is a standard
looking position but from colors reverse
and I would imagine and he finally does
play Knight to F3 that that would be the
most logical continuation to the left of
our board we see the win percentages in
high level games stemming from this
opening and white does have a slight
lead but many of these games are drawn
and that's what Dennis lazic is known
for it sounds weird to say oh that kid
is known for drawing but really he just
doesn't lose very often it doesn't
matter who he's facing it doesn't matter
what color he has he rarely loses games
of Chess and that includes over theboard
tournaments at the highest level it
includes the Champions chess tour title
Tuesday he is super solid and this is
anything but solid from Magnus Knight to
G5 I mean he's playing some offbeat kg
chess and if I'm Dennis I think I just
occupy the center I think I might want
to bring my knight up to D4 there are
oftentimes tricks available if white
isn't careful on this E2 Square so I
think that Magnus he's uh just trying to
catch Dennis off guard but Tanya this is
H still stable stuff from the
17-year-old and that's what he's known
for stable chess we seen him we've seen
his games very few times you'd see
Dennis make some decisions that leave
him with a long-term weakness he really
likes to play these strategic fights to
me it was really fascinating what you
said earlier when Magnus went into an
early think that he's just trying to
think where can he go where Dennis might
not be too familiar and he takes this
reverse Sicilian setup up a move simply
because Dennis is not an E4 player
himself so perhaps trying to get him
into Waters where Dennis might not be
too familiar but I like the speed with
which he's played I like the fact that
Dennis has kept a position which doesn't
have weaknesses eventually we might even
see a light Square Bishop trade it
wasn't possible on the previous move
because the Knight on D5 was H was
hanging but if black is able to trade
off that E6 Bishop for the G2 Bishop
very often black solves all opening
problems because the one Trump that
Magnus has in this position is the
bishop bar Robert yes this bishop on D2
that's supposed to be a beneficial piece
but there aren't useful diagonals to
with it staring into its own night there
are actually no accessible squares along
the diagonal as I'm putting them all in
red because black controls all of them
so so far it's been a stable game for
both of these players and Magnus as
David said I think he really called this
correctly he's just trying to get a bit
of a longer game and outplay Dennis
later on and we already can see that
with a semi-open C file there is some
valuable Terrain in front of this Rook
especially if this Knight moves out the
way David what do you make of this move
A5 I think it's it's clear that's why
Dennis Mar has effed d8 but do you like
the setup that he is opting for I think
it's uh very sound as Tanya mentioned
there Dennis has limited experience in
this porn structure and uh often if a
player I know the viewers at home might
be thinking this as well if you play a
new opening if you're forced into new
ground it takes a while to figure out
where to put the pieces but he's
defending everything here Dennis he's
going for centralization the White Queen
the white uh sorry the black queen the
Black Knights the black Bishop all
really well placed can't fault those and
now he's employing magnus's favorite
thing against him pushing Rooks pawns
just gaining space on the flanks it
always looks mysterious it always looks
like it's playing on kind of an
irrelevant side of the board but Pawn to
A5 if that blackborn pushes further
later on could become a real battering
ram it kind of takes away some of
White's major plans on the queen side
white normally would want to push Pawn
A3 B4 so um yeah I think Dennis has
handled this really well it hasn't cost
him that much time on the clock he's
still within his comfort Z got
everything covered um like you were both
saying he's just this immovable object
Dennis the Conqueror no no it's Dennis
the Invincible as long as he doesn't
lose he's uh he's happy so um yeah I
think in terms of objective evaluation
he's solved all his problems he's
totally fine as black it's just about
later in the game whether he can kind of
uh maintain that composure when Magnus
inevitably does start to ask some
difficult questions starting with this
move Queen to A4 um Robert a bit
tactically here suspect a queen on A4
often but here it looks like it's fine
for white yeah typically you take
advantage of a queen over here on A4
with tactics along the diagonal loose
pieces drop off you always have to
consider what happens if the piece in
between hops out the way I want to show
very quick variation so let's bring up
the analysis board because some players
might be looking for tactics on this
diagonal but Knight takes C3 removing
the guard of the queen after B takes C3
let's say you hop in with a knight to D4
I thought the evaluation would go all
the way up in White's favor but
apparently it's not that bad Knight
takes E2 check intermetzo was the point
the king slides to the corner Rook takes
D7 I thought that this Knight was just
trapped on E2 and it does look trapped
but amazingly this is ridiculous the
move that black has here is Bishop to C4
do see this and then to properly assess
I get it that you can't take the bishop
because the bishop on D2 is loose but to
consider this position here where at the
end of things white has two Bishops for
a rook and apparently it's just level
this is a rook in two pawns for two
Bishops yeah it's a mess but Dennis
maybe if he calculates this deep he can
go for this variation I thought it was
impossible but clearly there is a lot
that's going on here that does not
immediately catch the
eye but very often Robert it's not just
about calculating these kind of
variations but also evaluating that
final position as something that you
want on the board which can be very
challenging because to me looking at
that two Bishop versus Rook sure the
computer might say it's level but from a
human perspective you're never really
sure because the Bishops can be super
strong against The Rook so it's also
something that perhaps Dennis isn't
forced to go so he's trying to think of
many many different options it's the
kind of position where chess is a
complicated game you can have different
approaches different plans we see the
move Queen to A4 and Dennis needs to
think what pieces to trade maybe he
trades maybe he doesn't maybe he sidest
steps with the queen but he's taking his
time right now David what would be your
approach with black in this
position um I think I wouldn't go for
that line just because uh I'd probably
be too lazy to calculate in a rapid game
but also partly because as Robert said
it's so difficult to uh evaluate and
while Dennis he's just traded off the
night I believe night takes night we're
heading in that direction Dennis he's so
good strategically for such a young
player really mature his kind of
decision making his end game skills but
also very sharp in terms of of tactics
so I wouldn't have been surprised if he
did play Knight D4 but this is the
justification he didn't need to enter
those murky Waters it's not his
character he just wants to trade off
light Square Bishops as you pointed out
Tanya and he's doing it in a different
fashion but probably equally effective
white doesn't really want to run away or
or block this light Square Bishop trade
because that would really hamper the
activity of White's Bishops um I think
Dennis has made a good decision and if
we're left with just queen of Knight
versus queen of Bishop as we've kind of
touched upon before that Dynamic can
favor the side with the Knight so um
yeah again it cost him a lot of time two
three minutes Dennis but as we've come
to expect from him Robert always a sound
positional decision from him and
speaking of well unsound positional
decisions Pawn to F3 from Magnus the
evaluation bar doesn't really budge so
objectively this is a good call I
actually think practically it is too
because black had a clear plan let's
trade Bishops I do want to point out
that the tactic I was noting before
Knight D4 can always be met by Queen to
D1 to defend that loose Pawn on E2 here
you could successfully trade Queens but
I just want to note that that was not a
force variation but after F3 there isn't
anything forced for black now Dennis has
to make another difficult decision and
what is the actual plan Tanya I actually
I'm appreciating this move from Magnus
he is just keeping everything under
control on his end and saying to Dennis
what are you going to do I have the
bishop hair and in the long run the
Bishops May Flex their might on the
diagonals
keeping more tension on the board if the
Bishops are traded off it really helps
blacken the position the Knight better
than that Bishop it just makes things so
much easier F3 eventually black needs to
take a decision because Black's Bishop
on D5 isn't very stable it can be kicked
out it might even fall back maybe F3 is
a move that Dennis actually provoked to
block that Bishop but look at that last
move by Dennis he clears up another
Square on C6 for his own Bishop he
really wants to keep keep it on this
diagonal making sure that he can
neutralize the bishop pair that white
has I saw that evalar it did not approve
of this queen trade but from a human
perspective it looks like a very
practical choice to make
David yeah yeah it makes sense getting
the Queens off it simplifies things
somewhat but this is kind of Magnus
playing anti- young player chess you
mentioned it that phrase Tanya while I
was off camera I quickly got out the
Oxford dictionary I checked what that
meant and it's pretty much getting the
Queens off don't allow your opponent any
fun and any activity you take the
long-term advantages here Magnus has the
bishop pair we've talked about and also
the extra Central Pawn and uh with all
of those small imbalances you try to
tire out your young opponents and uh of
course Dennis is no ordinary yster it's
no guaranteed that it will work but I
think this is Magnus again as Robert
mentioned just kind of asking small
questions later he'll again start
creating threats start pushing the white
porns which pawns will he push who knows
Dennis isn't sure either so Dennis will
have to burn time watching out for moves
like F4 in the near future and um yeah I
I don't really like the fact that you
trade traded Queens yes it made things
more simple but remember Bishop peirs
gaining power the longer the game goes
on the more the board clears up so uh
this end game I would think against
anyone in the world it would be a bit
more one-sided um Magnus is on the white
side but yeah Dennis if he proves yet
again as he has done this whole week
that he can hang in these tight end
games against the world's best then he
will deserve uh this result
F7 what do we think of that R I like
that move from Dennis at some moment he
can consider bringing his Bishop back to
D7 and F4 that's the big idea for Magnus
creating a pawn break but perhaps Dennis
won't allow the pure break and will push
himself to E4 just trying to ask
questions to White's Pawn structure so
so far there hasn't been pieces staring
at one another we're just seeing some
maneuvering but I do still think that
White's plans are easier and it's in
part part because there are more pawns
for white in the center we see two pawns
for white one on D3 one on E2 just one
for black and we have lovely Pawn chains
for black the pawns are a bit scattered
and I do think that at some point white
will play F4 you just have to time it
correctly and meet E4 with D4 so tell
you I think that Magnus he's in a
quintessential Magnus
position you've put it really well and I
don't think there's anything scarier
than playing Magnus in these kind of end
games where m modles like us might be
like this you know eventually we'll
fizzle out into a draw one of the minor
pieces might get traded off no
weaknesses for black matus Carson is
already smelling blood here he's got the
bishop pair he's looking longterm he's
placed his rook in B1 F4 always in the
air although the last move by Dennis I
like it he puts that pawn on B6 you want
to place as many pawns on the dark
squares to limit the activity of that
dark Square Bishop that Magnus has
because that's the bishop that Dennis is
lacking in the position he's moved the H
Pawn I won't be surprised surprised if
you might see G5 on the board as well
trying to restrict that F4 break that
you were earlier alluding to uh Robert
it's far from over but playing against
Magnus this is this can be a terrifying
position uh
David yeah for sure um this position
actually did appear on page 83 of
growing like a Grandmas so Magnus has
studied it before and pawn to F4 robt
it's this big question what to do black
has to break the beautiful Pawn chain
that black has from G7 to E5 you have to
uh make a decision now to block it lock
it or just try to I was about to say
maintain the status quo but you can't he
does indeed push his born forward what
do you make of these changes in
structure well I do like how quickly
Dennis is responding uh he is trying to
control the light Square so if the
Bishops had been traded then that Knight
would have just hopped into F5 but for
now that Knight on E7 it's a bit
restricted pie is fighting for the same
squares I won't be surprised if Magnus
uses his King but don't rush a decision
like that because that's some moment
black can strike pushing this E Pawn
forward but if this white king I'm just
going to teleport it on over to E3 this
is a problem for black in many of these
positions I'm just you know hovering the
king over the square I'm blockading I'm
putting pressure on your E4 Pawn so this
E4 Pawn the main point is overextended
atata I still don't see easy plans for
Dennis he's shuffling back and forth the
engine isn't suggesting it's a winning
Advantage for Magnus nothing of the sort
but he just his moves are just always
easier to play I think D just has to
wait right now he has to keep shuffling
with the Rooks like you mentioned keep
the position as is and let Magnus show
what is his improving technique here he
plays the move E3 so making sure that
black doesn't have that E Pawn push
anymore which at the right time would
have activated that Bishop gets the
other Rook into the game to me it's
really impressive the speed with which
Dennis is responding a position that's
slightly passive for him because for
Magnus he's playing not only the board
but also Dennis's clock so Dennis needs
to make make sure that he has those
extra seconds that extra minute when
those critical decisions will have to be
made and they will come when you'll have
to decide which pawns to trade which
pawns to push in this position do you
ever want to make a move like G5 do you
just want to stay still so there are
some big decisions ahead on the road for
Dennis I like his speed David how do you
think you know Magnus best what do you
think is going on in his mind right now
how does he see this being played out
Magnus is just calculating I think he's
turned off the emotions here it feels
like Magnus has upped his game from
yesterday where there was a a bit of
inconsistency there are a few slip UPS
here and there he's just gone back to
basics Magnus kind of 1.0 the Magnus who
first break broke onto the scene where
it's just about grinding himself and uh
kind of look at this por to C5 now
undermining Black's stronghold on the
queen side I think this is Magnus
zeroing in you mentioned being oppressed
by Dennis the speed tan I was too but
suddenly I look at the clock and he's a
minute and a half down suddenly The
Black Queen side on the verge of
collapse uh so yeah it feels like Magnus
is again keeping things simple Rook to
B2 there just covering the A2 Pawn soon
the white light Square Bishop will come
into the game there we go it rots itself
and yeah I've got to say I'm very biased
towards the white position right now it
looks like black is just really tied up
defending everything and no active plans
um whe the Breakthrough is who knows uh
Magnus and Dennis both know better than
I do but right now it does look like
White's Advantage only growing kind of
incent stepbystep R every single move
and this Pawn on A5 is just such a
problem piece for black to deal with
this Pawn back on A7 you'd feel like
youd a healthier structure for now the
Knight on C8 can't easily get out
because you might drop the B6 Pawn you
don't want to take on C5 because then A5
will drop so here it's about making that
incremental progress that we're talking
about Bishop to E2 at some moment to
also play G4 further expansion but if
you start trading pawns it gives the
black Rooks some file so I love the way
Magnus continues to play his Rooks have
chance I don't care about that question
where get out of here with that that's
not a question mark move and I don't
even know what black should do to
respond it says Black's best move here
yeah it wasn't gonna be played Knight to
E7 giving away this B6 Pawn so if that's
the way to get out of it you're not
finding that as a human with one minute
and 15 seconds on your clock Magnus is
doing everything right in my opinion he
controls this
board look at that last move Point A3
he's in Zero Rush at all again
instructive for everyone at home when
you have a long-term Advantage when
there's no immediate threats from your
opponent you don't need to rush just
slowly improve he's freed up that white
Rook on B2 now it will no longer be tied
down to that pawn as Robert mentioned at
some point he might even play King to G2
to defend the white H3 Pawn uh kind of
let the light Square Bishop loose to
start playing and Denis every single
move he's asked with a question what are
you doing how do you improve black Camp
cannot improve his position cannot
create any threats and that Burns time
on the clock look at this 30 seconds
Tanya the time situation it looked under
control but suddenly no longer it's
always so impressive how easy Magnus
makes these end games look he has this
unique ability to combine all these
different aspects in the position he
first advances on the king side gains
the space slowly improves the king puts
the Rooks on the
correct uh the correct files which
potentially long-term can open up so
they're ideally placed meanwhile
blackrook doubled on the Deep line but
they're undermined by that D4 Pawn The
Bishop's coming into play small moves
like A3 forcing Dennis to make a move
which is much harder when you lack
spaces and for Magnus Carlson it just
feels like the Magnus magic when it
comes to these end games and look at him
on the camera he looks so incredibly
confident and now Dennis has to hold
this position with just 20 seconds on
the clock complete control from Magnus
Carls and every single little move a
pawn push to get off the dagine by the
way Dennis is getting really low on time
and that's when the mistakes happen
Advantage growing and Bishop E2 a
correct response keeping that King
Frozen opening the CNB files but where
is The Knockout there must be something
here or at least in the near future as
Dennis is under 10 seconds David and
there we go Magnus opens up a second
front of attack he's already probed away
on Black's Left Flank now he's switching
focus and hoping to overwhelm the black
Army and wow every move suddenly it's
King side then Queen side King side and
queen side and there we go Rook C6 he's
infiltrated Enemy Lines he's into the
sixth rank that black knight is so sad
right now Dennis's time situation sad as
well eight seconds left it's on the
brink of collapse as you say Robert
still yet to uh kind of click that
Domino flick it and uh for everything to
start toppling but Magnus is looking for
the Breakthrough um and here there's so
many tempting moves right now for white
lot of tempting moves and it's also so
instructive how Magnus kept improving
his position made these small moves and
only went for the G4 break when Dennis
was down to seconds because it's such a
difficult move to respond to and he
might give a check on C4 right now I
don't believe you can fall back with the
bishop I'm already looking at ideas like
the D Pawn moving forward and that would
have been tactics that would have worked
in magnus's favor it just looks like
Black's pieces are losing Harmony right
now The Rook is active the Knight on C8
there has to be something really strong
right now can white start thinking about
advancing the D Pawn does he put
pressure on the C8 Knight what's the
move here too many good options I'm
actually not sure nor is Magnus that's
why he's doing the right thing he
slowing down he pushes his Pawn to D5 it
opens up a diagonal for the dark Square
Bishop but look at Dennis he is hanging
in there he may have seven seconds left
but his last few moves have been solid
Magnus is like how do I actually win
this game because if Dennis gets his KN
out watch out mean suddenly this becomes
a bit messy and White's King is feeling
a little bit lonely there could be
checks against it and things of that
nature Dennis he's so resourceful we wow
Magnus sacrifices The Exchange I was
about say Dennis NY never loses because
he defends better than most players in
the world and suddenly he's oh he's
given up another Pawn on the A5 Square
magnus's D Pawn looks huge he played
that last move with three seconds left
Dennis it might be the crunch of time
trouble here a pin he needs to react he
defends his Bishop magnus's Bishops are
going to become monsters there we go
another Pawn drops it's Bishop and two
pawns for the rook and a check has
Magnus seized it now Dennis shaking his
head Robert he's on the brink yes a win
for Magnus Carlson resignation but it
was time that did Dennis lazic in you
see the last move a brilliant one giving
up his Rook for Bishop because the other
Rook was threatened but look at Magnus
quickly turns off his camera he wants a
little bit of a break and for Dennis
laik there are no breaks you're playing
Magnus Carlson in the best of four match
the first to two and a half wins and
Magnus Carlson gets game one den Les has
to score a win he can't just draw out
anymore I think DZ is just sitting there
trying to think what went wrong because
it's that kind of a game that you see
from start to finish and you can't even
point out where did it all go so wrong
for black matis just seem to outplay him
move by move slowly converting another
Magnus Masterpiece in the end game David
uh that one a true piece but grind like
a
grandm ah Magnus got the job done in the
end but it got a bit shaky Dennis did
get his chances towards the end so we
have to credit the youngster there for
defending tenaciously not panicking
ultimately though it was the combined
psychological pressure of facing Magnus
it was the board it was the clock and uh
yeah that was close I actually thought
suddenly we would see a turnaround there
and now it's just about how Dennis
recovers that was his first loss of the
whole of division one so far um only his
second of the chess ball Masters if we
count the plays so Dennis he's pretty
much a new terrain new territory great
fight from him but when you're playing
the world number
one tough Magnus looked ruthless there
um Robert what do you make of the second
game Dennis with white he's known to be
strong he's known to be strong but
Magnus Carlson is known to be the
strongest so for Dennis lack you know he
was in a worse spot Magnus showed
tremendous restraint and then he kind of
bullet chest him where Magnus had too
much time so Dennis lvic he trots out
his typical stuff and perhaps one of the
issues for Dennis is because he's such a
solid player he doesn't go off the
beaten path and he needs to take some
risk David you talked about a lot
yesterday from fedos se's perspective to
beat Magnus Carlson you don't want to
just play with a slight little advantage
and hope that Magnus goes wrong you have
to ask him really difficult questions do
you think this opening is actually one
that Magnus scares is scared of in the
least not yet uh Dennis might have to
add some spice in the near future uh
I've been lucky enough to play Magnus in
hundreds of Blitz Games and uh yeah as
you mentioned just there the only way
that he ever goes wrong is if it's a
totally irrational position where all of
us go wrong uh he is human but if you
give him a positional Advantage like we
saw in the previous game he's
Unstoppable Magnus Garson uh so here
Dennis he's going on the attack that
white knight jump attacked the black
Dart Square Bishop um this came from a
semi slav defense now a trade of Bishops
oh Magnus looks well prepared because
he's kicking the White Knight back black
is isolated Queen Pawn territory now and
black offering a trade of Bishops long
term it would uh at least conventional
wisdom would say that white is better
but Magnus has clearly studied this
before Tanya another default opening um
what do you make of the outcome here I'm
just amazed with the speed with which
the players are playing I'm not familiar
with this particular this exact position
Bishop G4 usually they say that when
you've got the isolated Queen spawn you
should avoid trades but I think the
reason that Magnus is going for Bishop
G4 for is because white is still behind
in development and actually taking that
bishop and G4 would have allowed Black's
Knight to jump forward and potentially
the queen to come out into activity
really quickly manness seems to know
exactly what he's doing in this position
and while D5 is a long-term weakness now
with provoking F3 E3 also becomes a
tender spot in White's position that's
absolutely correct and Magnus when
Dennis lazik played F3 was kind of like
hm this looks a bit odd to me but I
think he respected it because instead of
just trading off pieces it shows that
Dennis is trying to fight but the
problem here in this position as Dennis
he Retreats his Knight a defensive move
is that you need to you know find a
square to hop into you need to find a
Target to exploit normally that D5 Pawn
would be the issue but Black's one
Knight covers it and white can't easily
increase the attack against it so I love
the way that Magnus has handled it I
think he could slide his Rook to C8 as
well to force this Queen off of the open
line but for both both of these players
it's going to be about who comes up with
the Better plan because I think most of
their pieces are optimally placed at the
moment at
least and uh Dennis as we mentioned felt
to defeat in that previous game but he's
really raced out of the traps here he's
still got 9 minutes 20 he's made some
big decisions the youngster I'm going to
say impressive composure to just uh
recover so quickly to not go uh into any
long thinks early in the game trademark
move there from Magnus Carson again
mysterious Rooks push gaining space
stopping white from Gaining kind of
territory on that side of the board
watch out for that hwn to play a role a
bit later it always seems to when it's
Magnus Carson but in the meantime Dennis
I think in terms of a long game here
which is pretty much guaranteed to be he
would love to trade off the Queens as
white he would love to maybe trade off a
set or two of Rooks and uh slowly but
surely try to improve the white pieces
it's all about one problem piece one bad
piece makes a whole position bad they
say and White's Knight on F1 not making
a great impression right now um but yeah
it's still anyone's game it's still a
long way to go at least uh Tanya
compared to the previous game Dennis
doesn't have long-term issues here to
worry
about yeah but he might have short-term
issues to worry about with the hbond
moving forward now black taking control
of the SE file we might even see a
potential idea you said these are
magnus's uh thematic moves of trying to
go trademark moves maybe we might even
see an A5 A4 at some point trying to
undermine Queen side last game we saw
him play on the king side and the queen
side controlling the board but right now
it looks like Magnus just wants to trade
off as many pieces now traditional
wisdom is that again the more pieces
that get traded off the side that's
playing against the isolated Queen Pawn
white in this case if fa was white why
is Magnus so happy to trade these pieces
off Robert in this particular position
it's because he can't and he being
Dennis can't put the pawn back on F2 and
that's why his King went out here that a
Pawn's best friend is another Pawn you
want to keep little Pawn chains here and
there so that you don't have to use more
valuable pieces to defend them the
Knight on F1 that's not where it really
wants to be it's defending this Pawn on
E3 but the king jumps out to F2 I like
your idea Tanya A5 play A4 just create a
pawn break on the other flank because
there's a lot of tension in the center
and you could start trading pieces there
but white does have control of that open
file and okay Magnus he plays H5 he
plays A5 he is playing perfect chest in
this game I know Dennis is playing well
to but normally we talk about white
pressing for an advantage I I don't feel
like Dennis has anything that he can
strike at and so Magnus he's really
handling this
perfectly you know what I find the most
annoying thing in chess uh guys it's
knowing magnus' style knowing what he's
going to play but somehow not being able
to replicate his results his success
it's it's crazy we knew H5 was coming we
knew A5 was coming probably Dennis knew
it too but what do you do against it
it's just the timing it's just the sense
the feeling and yeah Magnus he's got
ideas like Pawn to A4 just disrupting
white over there Queen to B4 even at
some point might be in uh kind of a
factor trading off Queens but on Black's
terms and the central tension why break
it why uh kind of make things more
simple here for Dennis Dennis now going
into a longer think because it's so
tense and that is psychologically tough
when you're facing a juggernaut like
Magnus um so I think I get the
impression at least that we're slightly
favoring Black's chances or at least the
trend for black but uh Dennis he needs
to somehow make his Mark I think most
importantly he needs to not lose this
game just even a draw wouldn't be the
worst result gain a bit of confidence
against Magnus but uh a tough spot for
the youngster right
now absolutely and Dennis we've been so
full of Praise of his style which
predominantly is extremely strong
positional strategic understanding but
when you're playing against Magnus we've
often seen we saw it at the AI cup when
Maxim did did it he beat Magnus twice in
the Grand Final to take it that very
often you need to create these messy
chaotic complicated positions and I
think that is just something that's not
intuitively Dennis's style and then how
do you outplay a player like Magnus or
try to create chances in a positional
battle we saw the same narrative in game
one these slow moves by white when
Magnus played just slowly improving
position and you didn't even understand
where it all went wrong for Dennis and
I'm getting that same exact feeling in
this one H5 A5 not sure why white went
wrong but I'm liking Black's position
already I don't think that white went
wrong really at all I think that F3 move
did catch Magnus by surprise because it
gave Magnus a Target to look at but the
way Magnus plays in positions like this
it's tremendous understanding that H5 it
didn't necessarily carry this punch to
it you think H5 you're going for an
alpha zero like attack go checkm
something like that no it's just it's
restricting white David made this point
earlier that in many of these positions
white likes to expand because the white
king is actually quite safe out in the
open to play Move Like G4 unavailable
this move A5 is he going to play A4 or
is he just trying to give his Knight a
square of safety on B4 maybe even Queen
B4 at some point because when you trade
and take back with the pawn this Rook
can slide to an open file I know these
are some deeper Concepts but Magnus
Carlson truly understands these the ins
and outs of these positions and here's
another example you could take with his
Bishop on C6 you could take with the
pawn on C6 he takes with the pawn which
I do think is the best play but it
changes the dynamic where now the
eyesight Pawn is on A5 as a backward
Pawn on C6 and now Queen trade is on
offer David are you swapping Queens here
if you're Magnus or are you going to
avoid that for now a
swap and Magnus takes I'm actually
surprised I was actually going to say
the opposite like here it felt like
White's King potentially slightly more
vulnerable than its counterpart so
keeping coin on in that regard uh tends
to favor you U potential attacking
chances but Magnus he's at least
guaranteed that both sides have three
Pawn Islands here not only does black
have an isolated Pawn on A5 but White's
Central Pawn on D4 now um lacking any uh
real support so I'm surprised purely in
the fact that white has outposts now
like The Rook on C5 But ultimately it's
just the fact that the white is so bad
that I think Magnus can get away with
this and he's confident that he will at
least hold the ensuing end game um I
still very surprised it shows that
Magnus doesn't necessarily want to win
this game I think he's happy now to try
and guide this towards safety guide it
towards a draw But ultimately yeah a
sound decision that was a matter of
taste and Magnus maybe just wants to
hold this one strike with white yet
again in the next game uh Tanya do you
see Dennis potentially winning this
someday does he have any chances at all
I think it would be really impressive if
Dennis is just able to stop the bleeding
I think this is still a very level
position the reason I say that is
because there's always this counterplay
on the queen side with A4 at the right
moment right now Magnus has lined up
with Rook B8 and I think he has A4 in
his mind because it looks like a pawn
sacrifice but taking that pawn it's only
temporary black can even start attacking
it with Rook eight but also get Super
Active with the move Rook to B2 that
you're pointing out so with this queen
side looking like it's going to be
neutralized it's going to be liquidated
I think draw is the most likely result
what do you think Robert I never trust
anybody to draw against Magnus Carlson
in an end game I'm serious the amount of
times we've seen him win that look like
unwinable positions everyone else would
have agreed to a draw dozens of moves
earlier he outlasts his opponent and the
side that controls the pawn breaks is
often the side with the advantage here I
see a very simple Pawn break from the
black side I don't see the same from
White yes I can create some Pawn tension
excuse me with Pawn to G4 but after a
swap of Pawns you're just giving black
some key squares in the center of the
board so A4 is actually a big threat
Rook B4 at some moment can also be
annoying as David pointed out white has
an isolated Pawn to take care of so what
next for Dennis Laz because he dips
under three minutes he is the one in
immense time trouble I don't think
Magnus is playing this for a draw I
think he is looking for those chances
and A4 is certainly a big one
and the the clock you mentioned it there
Robert it really reflects the ease of
plans uh not just in end games in
openings middle games often the top
players they don't necessarily look for
uh an advantage the computer says is
plus 0.4 0.5 they would rather take a
position that is level but their plans
are straightforward easy U you've been
pointing out Pawn A4 Rook to B4 Black's
King is coming if you need on autopilot
Black's King has come to E7 D6 what is
white doing in the meantime Dennis is
yet to figure it out I don't don't see
any obvious moves either 2 minutes now
against almost eight yeah Magnus will
definitely get ambitious if this trend
continues Rook to C5 forcing Black's
reply but now A4 even more uh tempting
within the next few moves Dennis really
needs to pick up the pace maybe the
nerves now this huge occasion is getting
to him
T we started this with 10 minutes as
base time Magnus is at 7 minutes and 57
seconds the clock situation says
everything that needs to be said about
this Dennis is on the defense in this
one and Magnus is going to play this out
till the end Dennis still has to earn
the draw and I was a lot more hopeful
about that draw just uh just a couple of
minutes ago but after seeing the clock
situation I agree with both of you I
think Magnus is ambitious in this one
there's been nothing flashy about this
game you just saw the scorecard beneath
the players is saying that there were no
brilliant moves there were no really
moves deserving exclamation points just
because it's been an even battle you see
the accuracy 99.1 for Magnus Carlson and
and not too shabby 98.7 from Dennis
lasic the problem for Dennis is it's
taking him a lot of time to play nearly
perfect chess for Magnus his moves now
are more natural and he's been playing
the start of this game extremely quickly
so look at every turn from Magnus the
Knight on F6 dominated by Aon on F3
let's reroute that pony here comes the
Knight where where's it going Knight D6
maybe Knight C7 to E6 here it comes
watch out for the SL a dewn I am worried
about Dennis lzic position he's doing a
great job of keeping up the accuracy but
the way Magnus is playing and the speed
with which he's playing and look at his
face he just doesn't look bothered he's
just like okay yeah okay and just
another end game I'm gonna get this one
David he's grinding like a grandm if
I've ever seen someone do it exactly
he's uh just improving every single move
those black pieces are getting better
and better I wouldn't be surprised if he
plays to move Pawn to G6 now just to cut
out any jumps to the F5 Square there we
go on the board this is just typical
Magnus he's not playing complicated
moves anyone's capable of playing these
moves given a bit of time but he's just
doing it confidently quickly and um I
mean I've read an interview recently
about his uh World rapid Championship
triumphs and why he's so successful over
the other players he said he admits it's
because he's able to maintain kind of uh
this Tempo and uh he kind of trusts his
instincts he knows when to switch the
pace when to start improving just to
kind of go through this maneuvering
phase and then switch to start hustling
the opponent and I'm waiting for that
moment to start now 45 seconds against 7
minutes 30 he's going to start creating
threats in the near future trust me
Magnus and uh it's just about whether
Dennis can keep reacting he's held
everything together so far still great
accuracy 98.3 but it's only going to get
more difficult with every single move
Tanya it feels like it's all in Black's
favor white pieces are not better than
they were five six moves ago Magnus is
certainly are so instruct the way Magnus
has played this one out and once again
the break will come it might be A4 might
be something on the king side it will
come and it will be when Dennis is down
on the clock playing to seconds forcing
him to take a critical decision when
he's got no time on the clock and there
it is with 30 seconds on the clock
Dennis lazovic needs to decide what to
do in an extremely difficult end game
look at magnus's clock 7 minutes to boot
once again a master class on endgame by
Magnus gson
and Perfect Defense so far from Dennis
lavic but perfect can be the enemy of
the good he does not have time to
continue calculating here he's brought
his King and his Bishop to the defense
of the B Pawn at some point watch out
for move like C5 springing free that one
time isolated pawn it may be isolated
once again but that's also a pass Pawn
so Dennis has some tactics to look out
for he has some positional weaknesses
but he is doing the right thing so
credit to the youngster I would have
collapsed moves ago he is hanging in
tough in the evaluation bar it's not
budging because he's playing accurately
well done but the challenge continues
because Magnus hey he's
Magnus Dennis yeah I was raving about
magnus's end game play Dennis he's great
in this department I think that's why
we're so amazed by him why he's been so
successful especially in uh this these
time formats rapid and Blitz because
he's got such good instincts even with
20 seconds on the clock now he's finding
the right squares for his pieces he's
not allowed his weaknesses to be
attacked too easily he's holding
everything together and actually if
there is a trade of Pawns on the B3
Square which is very likely white will
potentially be left with a past Aon he's
got chances of his own so Dennis he's
been doing the right thing Magnus Now
using his time Advantage by pausing
sensing a critical moment again another
trait of a top player and um yeah it's
just about whether he can continue to
probe away and kind of trick Dennis
potentially in the near future the way
this is going it is black asking the
question but Dennis has all the answers
so yeah just high high quality chest
there we go a tra of Pawns and the
bishop recaptures Magnus selling traps
look at this a loose White Knight loose
pieces drop off Dennis under 20 seconds
he's got to react
now oh tan is hanging by a threat
already Rook to E1 looks a bit scary for
white tactically so sharp as well Dennis
he sensed it he knew that there's an
attack on the night Magnus immediately
played rookie it putting pressure on the
clock and Dennis rightly replied by
defending at night on E3 placing his own
Rook on that e file the pressure is on
and we've been talking about how Dennis
has been handling it so well hasn't
collapsed while many of the top players
would have by now against Magnus
especially but the thing is that this is
incremental slowly the pressure builds
on move by move it's really it just gets
more and more difficult to be accurate
I'm just going to be so impressed if
Dennis manages to hold this he's already
impressed all of us but this will be to
a whole different level if he manages to
draw this one well you use the word
incremental it's fortunate for Den laic
there is increment in this game because
he gains two seconds with every move
that he play so if he can pre-move and
play in one millisecond then he will get
time to rebuild on his clock as he's
doing right now Knight E3 it's given an
exclamation point I think it's the first
one we've seen today it was absolutely
necessary if a knight gets to F5 there
is some trouble Brewing on the white
king side so so far Magnus he's going
left he's going right he's bringing his
Rook to the center and all the way back
but he has not made any progress just
yet but for Dennis he needs to continue
to find these accurate defenses at some
point I think Magnus he may strike with
the c Pawn but David if you strike too
soon it can backfire oh I be see a
rapti you said it there the position
that was the second time we've seen that
Magnus plays for the win though if he
brought his Rook back to E8 we might
have been on for a draw there but no
it's like an exam for Dennis he's 17 he
should be doing exams he's being asked
so many questions uh Pawn A4 there he's
stopping the black knight from
activating with a
check still 11 seconds it feels like
time's disappearing so much faster uh
Knight to E6 now Magnus is just going
round in circles not actually doing too
much but every move there's a hidden
idea that Dennis has to react to 11
seconds we're going to keep talking
about the clock because right now it is
the most relevant Factor look at this
Magnus opening a second front again P
G5 and once again Magnus cson brings the
break when his opponent is down to
seconds has to take a decision he's
attacking the G3 Pawn but in return he
can simplify he can take on H5 uh give a
check many ideas on the board can he
actually just
go wow because of Knight F5 Yeah by
Dennis no don't apologize I think right
now Magnus he might need to apologize
for continuing to press because he may
have tricked himself Knight to E3 it
protects the pawn tactically speaking h
H5 can be captured now G3 can because
the bishop covered F5 but is Dennis la
playing for a
win the evaluation B really went on
white side there and Magnus reacted on
the camera what had he missed maybe
Magnus realizing that Bishop to A6 uh is
simply going to be blocked now trying to
hit that white knight is going to be
blocked by White's light Square bishop
and Magnus has the weakest Pawn of them
all magnus's H5 Pawn might just drop off
it's definitely Dennis playing for the
win applying the pressure he's a pawn up
he's a pawn up against the world number
one this has changed so quickly Magnus
needs to pull the break now and try to
draw it's not going to be easy though
this is a check Dennis six seconds left
but he's
better but there are tricks on the board
the A4 Pawn is hanging I don't see a
good way to defend that and Dennis going
for Black's King trying to get active
with his own Knight Knight F5 check
coming in uh first Magnus grabs the pawn
the Knight jumps in the F7 Pawn is a
weakness and can be a big Target I think
Dennis can start aiming for more here
this is going to be a bit of a pawn race
because black can take D4 white takes F7
and it's even material but we have two
sets of two pass pawns one for black in
the center here with C6 and D5 and white
will have f and g pawns it's usually
good to have outermost pass pawns
because they're harder to track down but
this becomes anyone's contest and the
good news for Magnus Carson as many fans
is he's got plenty of time but for
Dennis lvic what a speed demon he is
I think everyone's becoming a Dennis
lazovic fan David what incredible play
by him and he's going for it he wants
that pawn race he wants to trade the D4
Pawn for the F7 Pawn it's game on David
game on look at this the pawn race
begins black snaps off a pawn black has
two connected passes in the center but
White's f and g pawns will run super
fast wherever the black Rook goes next
move it has to move has to save itself
white is going to snap off that pawn on
F7 yes the evaluation Bar says equal but
this is far from a dead drawn end game
this is a 50/50 a total coin toss about
who's going to be quicker here White's
pawns just push them he gives a check
first of all Dennis Magnus
hides maybe if white pushes forward will
Magnus snap that pawn off I was going to
say he could have taken it forced a draw
but uh Magnus playing for the win Dennis
under 10 seconds oh Robert I'm funny
this so hard to predict every move it
feels like it could turn this feature
chat right now is spot on Dennis is
playing brilliantly he is not going to
bow down to the number one rated player
in the world and this is a g Pawn that
is running to the other side and it's
hard to stop the black king is in the
way of your own C Pawn you would like to
push the outermost pass Pawn so Magnus
and this isn't that simple sure he can
bring his King in and that actually
looks a bit worrisome but I think this
Pawn on C6 can it he grabb Dennis
answers the question immediately because
Black's Bishop's under
attack
great spot Dennis lazovic he's basically
secured himself safety now and Black's
Bishop attack gives itself up for the
highest price we're seeing this fizzle
out to a dead drawn Rook end game now
Magnus you can see on the camera he
knows no more winning chances this is
guaranteed to be a draw Dennis has
fought Magnus toe-to-toe on magnus's
home territory and held the balance we
see the position repeat itself and a
draw unbelievable what a Hold by danis
laig this is beyond impressive by the
17-year-old who played majority of the
game under 20 seconds on pressure every
single move finding the resources he's
impressed us a lot of times I have never
been more impressed than I am right now
with that draw against Magnus Carlson no
amount of Praise Robert is enough right
now for Dennis lazic that is certainly
the case because normally we're shouting
to the skies about winds and how great
that tactic was but that defense oh
goodness is you don't just find that on
the streets that is amazingly impressive
it's hard work it's persistence and that
was 98% accuracy most of which was done
with under 20 seconds on the clock so
Dennis lack he may be trailing right now
but Magus Carlson is looking at him like
wow this guy does not break he is a star
he's just 17 years old and he was able
to withand all of that pressure so David
I don't know how he does it that was
seriously
incredible that was yes another level
that was like seeing Magnus against mini
Magnus and not many people can fight
Magnus in that type of position let
alone with five six seconds on the clock
and I just wanted to praise Dennis's
calm uh composure at this moment here
after a lot of Maneuvers Magna Strikes
Out by playing the move Pawn to G5 a lot
of us would have panicked here after
this move for example taking this Pawn
now would have ended really badly for
white potentially this is a big weakness
the GN would have been a big weakness
after the black Rook swap instead Dennis
found a nice resource he did not capture
this Pawn he brought his Rook across and
uh yes the computer might have been
harsh about it but it was this moment
not reacting to this Pawn being attacked
not getting greedy and taking this black
pawn instead finding a night jump a
night Fork coming into F5 the pawn is
Untouchable and a few moves later we saw
actually Dennis start playing for the
win retreating his Knight to guard this
G pawn and as we saw in the game
magnus's H Pawn doomed Dennis for a
while was a pawn up actually maybe had
some small chances but Magnus finally
did pull the break Dennis went from
struggling to maybe even slightly better
with his expertise at handling that time
situation if he can play like that in
the last two games he has a shot so
impressive for such a young
player and that is one of the hardest
things to do in chess is to switch your
mindset when you've been on the defense
for the majority of the game when you've
been trying to hold your defenses and
Safeguard your position but then you
realize that an opportunity presents
itself and you can try for more Dennis
seized on it he did not back down
against Magnus Carlson he tried to win
the position when he had the chance and
that's a Champions mindset and
completely agree with you David if he
can keep this quality up the match is
far from
over sir feels like it's just heating up
we've had two games T we're only at the
halfway stage but it feels like we've
seen Dennis level up the first game
difficult but he really stepped up his
game and if he can keep doing that as
young players often do these days then
Magnus
beware yeah Magnus beware and we are up
for a big fight as two more games
remaining what a fantastic game too that
was by Dennis laake one thing's clear
it's not going to be an easy one he will
do everything to bounce back we'll be
back with more from the chessable
Masters
[Music]
in this video I'm going to show you top
five scholar made attempts in Champions
games before we dive into the games I
would like to show you the pattern if
you have not seen it yet well this
happens when white goes with one E4
black respawns with E5 and white plays
Queen to H5 this queen gets into the
game way too fast attacks the pawn on E5
now black plays Knight to C6 guarding
the pawn and white goes with Bishop to
C4 White's two pieces are attacking on
F7 and would like to capture this pawn
and if black is careless and plays
Knight to F6 then we have Queen to i7
and this is a Checkmate Scholars made
attempt two by Hikaru here we have this
game between Hikari and Philip of andon
and we have one E4 E5 Queen goes on H5
and G6 once again he Carl Queen to F3
once again gives a try to Checkmate
Black's King black says no I see that
and Knight to E2 we have seen already
this kind of position earlier in the
first game so black plays Bishop to G7
to make sure that King is castled and
here Hikari goes with D3 black responds
with D5 attacks right away in the center
white captures this pawn and black goes
with Knight to B4 the pawn on C2 is
hanging so white has to play Bishop to B
E3 to guard this pawn and now we have
Knight to D5 and here we have this end
game where white has very active pieces
both Rooks are controlling the open
files and the bishop is controlling this
diagonal as you can see here those
pieces are concentrated mainly on the
queen side and they are not actually so
active and the king is all the way here
on the king side just alone so white is
using this and plays Rook to E7 gives a
check if King goes on the back rank it
will be a Checkmate uh so black goes to
King H6 now and here we have Rook to D6
the pawn is hanging and it's not just a
pawn it's going to be a Checkmate so
King goes back on G5 plays G6 to guard
the pawn and we have Bishop to C4
attacking The Rook but what is actually
the idea of this move is that white
wants to play Bishop to D3 and check
made this King next
move there we go this is the Checkmate
that happened in this game and second
attempt of Scholars made in fact worked
out this game has ended in 39 moves it
was not a Checkmate in for Mose but I
think white got really nice play on the
king
[Music]
side
oh
the 17-year-old Dennis laic has done
what few players can do in the world a
difficult end game against Magnus
Carlson holding it with just seconds on
the clock Robert what was the most
impressive thing for you about the game
that we just witnessed all of it from
mag Carlson pressing and pressing
creating opportunities out of nowhere to
Dennis lzic playing at 98% accuracy the
whole way through despite being in time
trouble these two were very much even in
that game and you could see from the
history of it the trajectory it never
left the center point it was equal the
whole way Dennis Laz deserves a lot of
credit for defending just fantastic
fantastic play by Dennis but he has to
keep it going it's game three Dennis
will have the black pieces if Magnus
wins it's match over and Robert game one
was a complete Magnus Carlson show where
do you see Dennis switching it up are
you expecting a new opening approach by
Dennis I think that Dennis needs to play
Solly in this game with the black pieces
I thought that his opening was
absolutely fine but then things went
wrong after the queen trade so uh for
Dennis keep to what you know and then
with the white pieces maybe then take
some risk and I mean it's hard because
you don't know what Magnus is going to
play in any single
game David what do you think what are
you expecting from this big game three
coming up because Dennis has to keep
things under control in this one yeah
I'm expecting uh Magnus to minimize the
risk uh Magnus kind of historically he
wants to uh just kind of uh get a
position where he can press but uh pull
the break if he needs to for
Dennis it depends on his attitude a lot
of players are happy to just shut up
shop try to make a draw with black take
the kind of take the pressure the
Jeopardy to the final game where Dennis
would have white we know how strong
Dennis is with white after that last
battle but EAS set than done you don't
want to be passive you don't want to
play for a draw against Magnus so
actually if Dennis gets the opportunity
especially if Magnus freestyles like he
did in that first game of the day then I
think Dennis should play a bit more
ambitiously in the opening not
necessarily try to trade off Queens like
we saw um in that middle game earlier in
the meantime repeat until this last move
it's the English opening but a different
branch this time the Four Knights and uh
very similar with white fi doing the
bishop on G2 but Dennis getting the
black Bishop to a much
more same but different in h this
opening battle Robert and early days but
looks like both players are well
prepared well as you said the bishop on
C5 more active than it was in the
previous game uh for white adopting a
pretty similar setup so Magnus liked
what he saw of course he like the
outcome of that first game with the win
ananya I think really for Dennis the
biggest thing is playing a bit faster
it's hard because you're playing uh the
most accurate and strongest player but
you need to conserve some of that time
otherwise even if you get an even
position you may still collapse so what
do you make of this opening do you like
Dennis's play thus far and do you like
magnus's decision to just slightly
change the move order and the variation
it was so convincing what happened in
game one and that can also be
psychologically difficult for a Dennis
because it's the same opening but it's
different side variation of it a very
similar structure that we see and Dennis
is the one who has to switch it up he
plays magnus's trademark move as David
has told us with that a pawn moving
forward the bishop was attacked the
bishop falls back we're expecting a
trade on E3 but this is interesting
because whoever blinks with this tension
with a dark squared Bishop there are
repercussions on the pawn structure if
white was to take on B6 right now black
ends up with a double Pawn but in return
gets an open C line eventually will push
that a pawn to a four to undermine the
two pawns B2 A3 which have created a
weakness on the B3 Square meanwhile if
black was to capture on E3 it would have
resulted on a doubled E Pawn how would
you react in this kind of a situation
with this tension do you just keep it on
or do you trade
David it's always a question of whether
you can stand the tension Magnus cannot
he trades uh I was going to say try and
wait do it on your own terms Force the
opponent to spend their move capturing
but of course when changes OPP point
structure are involved um kind of all
bets are off you have to examine the
position for what it is and Magnus he's
got a very specific uh idea here he
wants to go in with the White Queen to
B5 potentially and start attacking some
weaknesses Dennis rubs his eyes there um
I think finally both players are out of
their opening preparation and uh he has
to figure out how to justify he has to
do it energetically but he has to
justify the compromised structure for
black you mentioned Tanya if the black B
Pawn starts moving you're totally fine
uh but for now that is
possible so yeah it feels like it's in
the balance evaluation Bar says dead
level but a little bit of pressure at
least psychologically on Dennis uh
Bishop to D5 though very quick idea and
uh kind of ruling out that that Motif I
mentioned Queen to B5 now would end up
on a vulnerable Square once the black
Bishop trades off for the White Knight
Black's Knight actually has a beautiful
post in the middle of the board and
highlighted there Knight to D4 so beware
this is getting tactical this is getting
sharp no no longer the slow strategic
struggle that we've seen actually in the
first two games I've got to say Robert
um kind of similar characteristics in
those first two games but this one could
come to life a bit more yeah now this
last move E3 it takes away the knight
jump that you were referencing with the
Black Knight wanted to step forward but
whenever you push a pawn you leave a
previously covered Square behind and D3
that's an eyesore in this position
because once the bishop moves out of the
path the D3 Pawn can be captured and
look at Dennis he's not just grabbing a
pawn because he can it wasn't the
computer accurate move I'm going to take
that question mark away if I can I don't
believe that's a question mark I'm just
going to say you know what the position
is equal you see what I did there equal
position and that is a perfectly good
move protecting your knight preemptively
and by doing so you can now perhaps take
on F3 under more favorable circumstances
because the series of Trades may still
be acceptable for black so it's an even
game Tanya I think that Dennis he has
done everything right this far but the B
pawns that's the long-term
issue completely agreed and I think that
move by Magnus placing the queen on A4
it's exactly why you want your queen it
it stops the advance of both the a pawn
and the B Pawn from moving forward
trying to create some kind of weaknesses
on the queen side that last move Rook C3
def defends the D3 Pawn that you were
earlier highlighting white is also
eyeing to get the Rook from F1 double up
on the sea line trying to get more
control of the O only open sea file that
said I think sl's position is also
really healthy yes there's a double Pawn
on the B file but the D3 weakness
compensates for those doubled
bonds Robert yeah highlighting that pawn
it's a key Square it's all about the
pawn structure here um I think black
needs to keep the Queens on due to the
compromise structure but uh in the
meantime it's white with the first
questions to answer Magnus hesitating
from playing the most natural move in
the position which I would say is Rook F
to C1 activating the white Rook this
doing nothing sitting at home next to
its king team up double up why not but
something has made Magnus pause and
maybe it's to do with the fact that
there are threats in the position
Black's Bishop can slide back attacking
the White Queen in the near future um
White's D Pawn is weak there might be
hits against the White Knight I feel
that that piece is slightly loose right
now and suddenly a lot of calculation to
be done and uh just if we compare this
game the time consumption due to
compared to the previous game Magnus he
doesn't look happy look on the camera
head in hands the previous game he was
up 6 minutes at this point Dennis was
down at 2 minutes he had eight he was
loving life suddenly tables have turned
uh far less oneway traffic it feels like
Dennis has really gained so much
confidence from that half point from
that earlier draw and uh Magnus
continuing to pause Robert do you smell
danger here what's he thinking about
he's trying to figure out you know what
is his actual plan yes Rook to C1 that
is the move I would play in bullet chess
i' probably play In classical chest as
well but he's trying to figure out where
is my next plan coming from because
let's say pretty much nothing happens
well how is white going to attack
anything I'm looking at some point to
make a move like D4 as Magnus does
double his Rooks I think that is the
Smart play but as Tanya and you David
both were saying earlier that if black
can successfully Play Bishop C6 and
start mobilizing the B Pawn I don't
think that you're too unhappy about your
position so it's a game of nuance it's a
game of tempo a Tempo and for Magnus
Carlson he properly assessed that he can
successfully get his Rooks in line with
one another and wow Dennis gives up the
SE file are you shocked by that at all
Tanya because he is playing natural
looking moves but now the open file is
Whit I'm loving what Dennis has done and
the confidence with which he's playing
this out he trades one set of Rooks
falls back with the bishop because now
they'll never be any problem of Rook
takes Rook on the back rack the Knight
on E7 doesn't need to keep that Rook
defended the bishop and C six blocks the
Open Sea line and the point is it's
going to be black spawns on the queen
side that are going to start pushing and
try and create weakness one Pawn one set
of Pawns get traded and the ones that
you're drawing arrows on if white is
left with that B2 pawn it becomes a
clear Target and it will not be the only
one the principle of two weaknesses
white already has a weakness on D3
Dennis trying to create another one B4
is a threat that Magnus now has to watch
out for and I think the fact that he
paused into good think Magus isn't
feeling very comfortable with his
position anymore David not at all Magnus
is on the back foot look at this black
is advancing black has a clearcut plan
we talked about ease of play how natural
it is Dennis he's going to push on the
queen side that's where he's stronger
that's where he has the poor majority
always play on the side uh where you
have more pawns or where you have the uh
the strengths there and um Magnus I
think he's playing to equalized he needs
to try and figure out how to trade off
pieces how to get this game to safety uh
I love the feature chat a moment ago
where it was saying Dennis he's mastered
the clock he's kind of controlling his
time so much better and this feature
chat too Dennis is confidence through
the roof he's now up over a minute on
the clock and Magnus no safety in sight
Robert it feels like at the right moment
I'm not sure now or on the next few
turns he has to play a move like Pawn to
D4 try and trade off everything just uh
try to bail out into uh a holdable
endgame Magnus because if you get hit by
B4 if you're still saddled with that
weakness on D3
Sur things will turn against him do you
think Magnus he's got safety on his mind
I think he should have safety on his
mind and Magnus Carlson he looks at this
position say I would probably prefer to
have this from black because the ideas
are more obvious B4 trying to create a
two onone situation allowing yourself to
have an outside pass Pawn later on it's
very obvious and for white D4 doesn't
actually carry a next move threat
because of the pins along the defile and
that's exactly why Magnus steps his
Queen Queen on over to E1 B4 to my eyes
it feels automatic but this E5 Pawn is
also loose you'd prefer to take with the
queen on B4 once the pawn trade happens
but with E5 hanging this actually
becomes quite a difficult decision I
like magnus's last move the evaluation
bar stays where it is maybe ever so
slightly preferable for black but a
complicated struggle so I'm looking at
this really with a fresh set of eyes and
I think that both sides have their
chances Tanya the one great thing for
Dennis his clock he is ahead on time
doing much better than in the previous
games the kids learn fast and Robert
danis realized in the first two games
the amount of pressure on the board and
the amount of pressure on the clock you
can't survive that in every game he
needs to keep the clock under control
which he has and impressively enough the
position as well Dennis right now
definitely has got all these ideas in
his mind he wants to make B4 work but
it's crucial it's critical that he's
able to recapture that pawn with his
Queen to put pressure on that second
weakness that we were talking about but
he goes for it is he thinking about
going Queen takes Pawn he whoa an
intermo he wants to capture it with a
piece jumps in with a KN and I see both
of you you're as surprised as I
am brilliant move just the vision the uh
kind of self-control not to
automatically recapture to look for
options and what could be better than a
hit on the opponent's Rook here with a
knight and Magnus might have to take
drastic measures we saw Magnus shaking
his head on the camera he goes for it
sacrifices a rook for Bishop and Dennis
raises his eyebrows double exclamation
mark now it's Magnus smiling What's
Happening Here some mind games at work
Magnus knows that he has now been forced
to sacrifice and gamble in a position
where he's a a point up in the match
shaking his head after this Rook is
captured white will take a Pawn on A5
white will have two pawns and a bishop
for a rook level material but so many
open lines you would tend to think that
a rook would thrive Robert it's suddenly
got chaotic Magnus what do you make of
his reaction he's just laughing but I
think he's laughing because he
overlooked Black's play and then he felt
fortunate that he had Rook takes C6
because this does muddy the waters
objectively it was the best decision we
saw it given the brilliant move glyph
and it was a brilliant decision but I
think it's because Dennis lzc is the one
posing the problems and I love the way
that Dennis continues C5 he is freezing
White's pawns they're not going to get
connected this Knight can in the near
future go to B4 also A6 unavailable to
White because the queen is opened up
along the sixth rank so I do think
Dennis is playing the better game
between these two we see that the
accuracy is about level but the mistakes
that have been made are worse on Magnus
aside than whatever mistakes Dennis
might have played thus far so the clock
in Dennis's favor he has a rook to a
bishop and a couple pawns but those
pawns are separated I'm liking Dennis's
chances here and Magnus he has a lot to
prove just just incredible stuff he's up
on the clock but let's do a a matth
count here Dennis has an exchange but
Magnus has two pawns Magnus has two
pawns on the bishop for a rook so it's
level so far but exactly the pawn
structure that you were alluding to
Robert it creates weaknesses black can
start targeting these pawns and if
Magnus isn't careful with these pawns
they start falling this is game Dennis
then the Knight can jump to B4 start
attacking the D3 Pawn The Rook can slide
over to B8 start targeting the B2 Pawn
the queen can slide to A6 start
targeting the targeting the A5 and D3
Pawn there are lots of pleasant options
for Dennis meanwhile it's Magnus who
needs to be
precise I don't know if I'm overstating
this or not but to me David it feels
like so far Dennis has outplayed Magnus
in this game totally I 100% agree uh
tables have totally turned since the
first game of today Magnus is way behind
on the clock look at the evaluation bar
slipping as well the margin for error
for Magnus is Tiny Dennis is just
playing Amazing chess right now and
Magnus we see just below the board that
game review Magnus has found one one
incredible move one excellent move
double exclamation mark but that was
just to hold the balance and he's going
to have to continue playing uh
brilliantly just to make a draw here
look at Dennis closing in the blue arrow
gave it away that was Black's best move
he's zeroed in he's going to capture
that weak white D Pawn we've been
talking about for a long long time maybe
even now that pawn could just be snapped
off the board The Black Queen doesn't
necessarily need to capture yet it would
also cost the ewn in the near future but
uh Dennis he's the one making magic
happen he's nearly two minutes up on the
clock and Robert I think this is his
opportunity in the match he needs to
strike now this might be the only chance
he gets against Magnus and for all of
our intermedia players in the audience
when you get a position like this from
the white side and this is what Magnus
he's going through uh these wheels are
turning in his head he wants to figure
out what pieces can be traded ideally he
eliminates all of the queen if he can
eliminate the pawns that I'm going to
put in red he's giving up three white
pawns for two black pawns he feels much
happier about his position because the
pawns are all on one side of the board
so there is an extra Rook compared to a
minor piece and white has two pawns for
that material deficit but as he
envisions the Future Works his way
towards drawish positions not
necessarily A draw that's what he is
aiming for he wants to give up D3 right
now to take E5 he'll give up his 2 and
A5 pawns just to get the C5 pawn and if
we can just liquidate Hoover off all
those pawns then suddenly you feel
better with just pawns on one side of
the
board Queen takes D3 played and now
Magnus the blue arrow again saying that
retreating the bishop is key that's not
obvious that's by far not obvious Knight
takes Pawn is probably the most natural
move right now but there might be some
issues on the back rank watch out the
white king the White Queen they lined up
if the white if the black queen moves
out the way the black Rook infiltrates
it's just game over so already Magnus
living life on the edge Dennis he looks
so confident look at him lean back on
the camera there 17 years old but he
knows he's a real boss already how
obvious do you think that is for Magnus
right now Tanya Bishop to F1 maybe the
only move to survive it's so tough right
it's a retreating move you're not taking
on E5 but of course it's Magnus Carlson
and he of course he finds the best move
but the troubles are far from over black
can also step forward with the queen I
really like the idea that you're
pointing out Queen C2 start not only
hitting and eyeing that B2 Pawn you got
ideas of Rook jumping onto D1 at some
moment the Knight jumping onto D3 but
Dennis instead chooses to fall back
which apparently turns out to be the
best move I see the evalar doesn't react
says why give up that E5 pawn queen D5
keeping everything under control Robert
you were talking about trades of Pawns
meanwhile Dennis has picked up one pawn
and not given any of his well the same
mental exercise that Magnus was doing
Dennis he understands the same and you
look at this that's why he brought his
Queen to D5 the queen cannot slide into
F3 that is a really difficult move to
play you're giving up your E5 Pawn with
the tempo against the queen on F3 I
don't know how likely this is unless
there is a direct path forward but I
feel like the blue arrow telling us it's
the only move that keeps the advantage
as big as it currently is almost two-
Pawn Advantage for black I think that's
not very likely David how about you I'm
on your team Robert as usual but uh
giving up a pawn it's not Dennis's style
unless he can guarantee he's getting
something back in return Queen F3
allowing a pawn to drop with a hit on
the black queen I don't think it's going
to happen uh also there are so many
other tempting moves you can push that
pawn to E4 just cement it um I guess you
can move the black Rook you move the
black queen the Knight jumps in instead
also a really nice move he's actually
allowing that ewn to fall but he's
saying okay if you take my Knight I will
recapture I'm going to trade off Queens
I'm going to try and simplify down where
my black Rook will beat your black uh
your white knight so uh Magnus now
forced to push a pawn to B3 but the bar
only drops further and now the idea of
Queen to F3 makes much more sense than
it did earlier because you hit F2 you
can close in move in for the kill the
white king is a Sitting Duck I think you
might play that move it looks uh by far
more natural compared to one move ago
Tanya you hit F2 and hit the D1 Square
white doesn't have the time to take that
Knight on D3 and capture on E5 because
after Bishop takes Knight Rook takes
Bishop Knight takes Pawn Rook to D1
check would be game over so Queen to F3
I love it and if tennis finds this move
Magnus will be in big trouble I want to
hear it from chat and I want to hear it
from you guys given this position both
players under 2 minutes Dennis lazovic
plays Queen F3 what are the chances of
Magnus saving this
uh they don't look good but there is
this outside pass pawn and that is
dangerous there are some loose Pawns in
Black's position and it's not readily
apparent how you deliver the checkmat so
David I would say that Dennis has great
winning chances I don't know what number
to put it but I'd say more likely that
he wins than Magnus holes and oh Knight
C1 what is
this wow the Black Knight goes on a limb
down onto the white first rank to hit
the White Queen White counterattacks
Magnus now the black queen and again the
blue arrow says that Black's best move
by far is to retreat the black queen and
queen exchange actually white would
potentially be saved but he finds the
best move double attack simply hitting
the White Queen hitting the White Knight
Dennis we were doubting him but why he's
actually threatening some nasty
checkmates as well the black Rooks
coming down to D1 and then taking the
white
Bishop is just I think it's almost game
over Robert has it just W on the spot
it's exactly what I just covered that he
is going to Checkmate the white king the
Knight on C1 yes it hits the queen that
looks like it's the job it's doing it's
actually taking away an escape square a
future Escape Square from the white king
So a brilliant set of moves from Dennis
lvic a queen E4 at this stage yeah that
move became much more natural to his
eyes but he just outplayed Magnus
Carlson in this game and excuse me is
that not a free night isn't Dennis lazik
about to be up an entire
Rook I am my freaking loone right now he
does a pickup that night it is an entire
Rook it all is down to that a pawn just
needs to block this out but perhaps he
can actually even still try to just go
for checkmate you can still try to
double up on that I'm trying to think of
how you can deliver that mate on H1 is
that a possibility but maybe you have to
be a little careful maybe you're not in
time with Rook D1 because A7 is a threat
David how do you parry this what is the
quickest way to wrap this up because
Rook D1 A7 looks scary it looks scary to
allow counterplay right now and uh why
allow counterplay when you've done the
hard work you have an extra Rook uh at
the very minimum black can go back the
black queen can start retreating the
black Rook still covers the promotion
Square for now but uh obviously if you
start retreating uh you feel like you
lose a bit bit of momentum uh but Dennis
what will he play an obvious move like
Queen to B8 Queen to C7 they should be
fine but uh he still wants to be
accurate look at the nerves on the
camera Dennis he's suddenly he's
scratching is uh kind of feeling the
tense uh W the stakes here Queen to D5
walking into a light Square diagonal but
covering the promotion Square I like it
Robert White Bishop is stuck in two
minds it wants to kick away this black
queen but it will always open up the
white king to checks if it ever moves so
I think he's doing a good job for now
Dennis lavic still some hurdles to uh to
get through though Magnus would love to
play Bishop G2 but it walks into
Checkmate so he first pushes Pawn to A7
now the good news is one square away
from promotion the bad news it's easier
to team up on and it can't be defended
by a light Square Bishop so Queen B5 the
the plan is clear for Magnus Queen to B8
check and then he may tie all of Black's
forces down under 17 seconds now for
Dennis Lac he's in huge Time Dr and fact
the engine is heading back towards the
center Queen d8 an inaccurate Choice
here it was a Miss but this position is
really challenging for him to survive
and the F7 Pawn uh oh that's a big
problem oh my gosh oh this is T he gives
up the Black Knight he offers it as bait
to try and deflect the White Queen
double exclamation mark Queen takes
Knight black will remove that white A7
point and black will win this game
brilliant F from Dennis lazovic there
but Magnus is still fighting what about
the F7 Square we mentioned Tanya Bishop
C4 you don't take the Knight you don't
give up your key Pawn e A7 but now
there's a double threat the Knight on B3
Hing the pawn on F7 Dennis says you can
take a Pawn on F7 it's only a check my
king is super safe on h8 there are no
more checks to follow and now the C Pawn
can start moving forward is Bishop D5
and idea but the point is that black
will capture the A7 Pawn eventually
capture that Bishop on D5 so Bishop D5
is not a resource for white Robert here
he's trying to put pressure but Dan is
still in driver's seat this Pawn needed
to be on e4 the bishop needs to safely
hit D5 but as you said The Rook will
distract que Magnus himself now he's at
10 seconds he also seeing a pass Pawn
run up the board Bishop G6 it makes a
around the king but look at Dennis go
it's the white king that isn't safe
either and Black's pass Pawn is just as
dangerous as
white is winning he knows he's winning
it's only the clock that can stop him
now Magnus at 1 second he moves his
Queen but now a check surely Dennis has
got this in the back he just needs to
get rid of that white Aon and he's going
to do it he's going to win this game
he's going to beat Magnus
Carlson him now
surely Dennis is seconds away from from
what is the biggest win of his career
but watch out there is a Checkmate in
one how do you fight it do you push the
Jeep on do you slide up with your king
he does it he is fighting it but he
still needs to be careful Magnus is not
going to let this be easy there's so
many checks against that black king
there no Pawns in front of it and here
comes another mating net the queen can
slide back to H7 at any moment but he's
ready to take this Pawn on E6 Perfect
Defense from Dennis
wow amazing defense look how he's
organized himself The Black Queen now
defending the king the black Rook on a
nice safe Square the Black Knight is
defended as well Magnus swearing Magnus
cursing his luck here he knows Dennis
has done perfectly and he's about to
lose with white Magnus this nearly never
happens the pawn drops Magnus resigns
Dennis takes a historic
Victory Dennis lawick with the biggest
win of his career takes down Magnus
Carlson with the black pieces
unbelievable the
17-year-old has done it
Robert he continues to shine on the
brightest lights in the biggest stages
and he is just Dennis the Menace that's
his nickname a loving nickname from me
because not only did he get here by
beating hiar Nakamura Anish giri Maxim
vasher lra and Jose Martinez he just
scored his first victory in Rapid chess
TI patrols against Magnus Carlson the
highest rated player in chess history we
talk a lot about these teenagers around
the globe often Dennis lasc is
overlooked overlooked certainly no more
he beats Magnus Carlson with black we
have a tied match well who's the
favorite
now oh my gosh I just cannot get over
what we just witnessed I mean that game
from start to finish Dennis always
putting the pressure on winning that
exchange getting that material advantage
winning those pawns putting pressure on
Magnus King what a Flawless play and
then defending to Perfection his own
King David that was a Master Class by
Dennis against Magnus Carlson not
something you get to see every
day that was really really something
special Dennis lazovic that was sick
that was just a brilliant Victory from
him uh I mean just the calmness as well
he won the material he converted it so
smoothly and Magnus was still creating
threats all the checkmating patterns so
easy to go wrong 5 seconds on his clock
every single move having to just trust
his instincts but Dennis lazic he's
probably the most confident chess player
in the world right now especially after
that Victory and I'm not writing him off
with white he's extra strong uh Magnus
really needs to be uh on Red Alert right
now this next this fourth potentially
final game wow uh Tanya Robert all bets
are off who could have expected
this I'm going to say not me for sure
especially after Magnus getting that big
first game win and the style with which
he won it I thought that there's a big
chance this might be match and three to
Magnus but with that comeback in game
two saving that big draw and then the
style with which Dennis just won this
one Magnus Carlson knows this is a fight
for his life this game for Dennis lavic
starts with the white pieces it's not
just the win but the quality of play by
Dennis in that previous match Robert I
just I don't even know what to say about
Dennis right now I'm just so beyond
impressed by him well one and a half one
and half is the score it's also very
fair because for the first game and a
half it was all Magnus in game one he
had got the upper hand early he was able
to convert to a full point in game two
he started his frustrating path forward
because Dennis lavic was a a roadblock
he was that immovable object and for
Magus Carlson you could see like there
are nerves on his face right now because
with the black pieces against someone
like Dennis you can't take unnecessary
risk it doesn't pay off for the most
part so Dennis lawick this is his first
time in the Winner's final he would love
to get to the Grand Final in division
one of the chestle Masters the first two
and a half points takes the match we're
at one and a half one and a half tie the
next win it's match
over they're off it's game four and a
Queen's Gambit declined black not taking
on C4 it's the slav defense where we see
a repeat of game two of this uh Winner's
final no Dennis lavic switches things up
he pushes upon Pawn where earlier he
brought the White Knight out uh so
Magnus the first to pause um the first
to think we could see still see similar
positions trans positions but Magnus
regaining his composure here Tanya what
do you make of his body
language really and understandably it
seems to have affected Magnus it
definitely did we saw him at the end of
game three Magnus was angry he he was
swearing right there he he couldn't
believe what had just happened we could
see that on the camera and now he's got
to come back but the one thing that's
scarier than Magnus is an angry Magnus
and that's what Dennis has to face right
now with the black pieces Magnus going
for the slav he goes for this bishop G4
variation it's not one that I've played
with the black side Robert break down
the plans for us how do you see this one
progressing and is Magnus just trying to
stop the bleeding and take this to
Armageddon Magnus is taking the solid
approach because as we look at the pawn
triangle in the center black has all of
these pawns on light squares only white
has a light Square Bishop so for Magnus
Carlson you typically prefer to play
with a pair of Bishops as a high level
player but he's saying that I've shut
down open diagonals even Pawn trades
won't give it the full length of the
board that it would like to use to its
Advantage so I think Magnus he just
wants to play quickly he wants to play
solidly but David I mean look at his
face he is still bothered about what's
just
happened um understandably as we said
Magnus he's the number one he's the goat
for a reason and he's not used to being
in situations like this where a young
Pretender a young Rascal comes along and
uh kind of knocks him and kind of
threatens to kick him off his perch but
um yeah he needs to recover Magnus and I
think he's doing the right thing I like
Black's opening Choice here I like the
fact that Magnus has gone for this
really renowned uh solid variation
because ultimately Dennis doesn't want
to take too much risks either yes he's
riding a high yes he just beat Magnus
but it's not his style Dennis to kind of
uh kind of set the pace to be the one
pushing and pushing and kind of taking
risks so Magnus he's saying okay if you
want to win come at me uh I'm happy to
just recover and uh as you mentioned
Robert Rock Solid from black the pawn
formation the skeleton of Black's
position no real issues here yet at
least um does have a reputation I've
played this myself of being slightly
passive for black again white has the
bishop pair a factor we talk about
longterm but uh ultimately yeah this
game I think it could have gone worse
for Magnus if he'd uh kind of been too
emotional and wanted to strike back
immediately so he's just trying to now
with this trade of Pawns break open the
center I'm expecting Pawn to E5 now and
he's trying to neutralize Dennis try and
get out of this game and I don't think
either of us would complain right Tanya
if uh we saw ndon absolutely I think uh
if this match goes down to the V if any
match deserve to go down to the V it is
this one and it's going to be a spicy
armagedon speaking about who wants to
push well Dennis isn't going to be a
push over in the armagen he's taken down
Anish gir he's taken down Maxim VRA in
the chessable Masters in the Armageddon
he's going to be taking a lot of
confidence from that the E5 break that
you were alluding to in the current
position I think that's definitely on
magnus's radar he's just preparing it a
little bit first falls back with that
Bishop white can start pushing ing his
own Central pawns try to take uh that
space with E4 which I think will be met
by your move E5
David on the board and uh at least E4 is
with a big big threat white wants to
play E5 so surely black has to stop it
here um that would be a for a double
attack if white steps forward one more
square and there we go Magnus does
indeed block and uh now okay Dennis
advances locking the center sometimes uh
not favorable if you have the bishop
pair but here it's all about control of
the light squares Magnus doesn't want to
allow white to sit with a protected pass
Pawn forever but if he ever trades on
the D5 Square White's light Square
Bishop will gain in power Robert I like
Dennis's last couple of moves he's
showing ambition here it looks nice for
white this bishop on C4 is a much better
piece than it was a few turns ago
because that pawn triangle all in light
squares blocking its diagonals that's no
more and it will open up towards the
black king at some point but look at
Magnus he says all right I concede that
your Bishop will be strong but how about
my Bishop on C5 how about some of the
control that my Knights will get this
Knight can wrap around to B6 at some
moment so both players they need to
figure out what the optimal squares are
for their pieces and it's actually not
that easy one big decision is should
white take on C6 to isolate both of
Black's queenside pawns but isolated
poll open files an open B file could be
useful for black and that's why Dennis
he keeps the status
and he maintains a slight
pull I think this one is very likely
heading to that Armageddon that we're
looking at with that last trade and a
queen trade being offered to Magnus
you've been talking about body language
looking at him uh David I think this
game for him is about calming down and
just knowing that you know with the
black pieces doesn't want to lose
control of anything and we take this uh
fight there but now the big question is
do you trade Queens especially against
Magnus
hair normally I would say no don't do it
against the best endgame player of all
time the endgame Maestro himself but
here you do gain a bit of time
potentially he drops back though Dennis
lavic fearing those words maybe echoing
in his ears don't trade Queens against
Magnus but uh now at least the structure
changes and um Dennis I was going to say
is he going to take back with a pawn
maybe the most ambitious move but be
settled with an isolated Pawn of his own
uh or does he play it safe does he take
back on this square with a piece the
bishop the Knight um sport for Choice
here and at least on the camera visibly
Magnus seems to have calmed down Robert
what do you make okay of this Knight
capture from
Dennis I thought we might get this
continuation because the risk associated
with isolating your own Pawn sure you
would have had a pass Pawn I don't think
that's Dennis's style I don't think he
wanted any part of that and this looks
very level and this move Queen back to
E7 it's so that when or if black takes
on D5 and The Rook takes back the queen
isn't hit so it's a bit of a
prophylactic move it's a defensive move
and I actually think that if Dennis
isn't careful Knights can outclass
bishops because this bishop is on its
optimal square but later down the line
if you can Envision a knight somewhere
out on a important dark Square maybe F4
maybe D4 it's a long ways away so I
don't think it's going to happen but
Knights can be very jumpy tricky pieces
so Dennis just can't assume it's going
to be a draw Magnus he typically plays
on if there's any life
left magus doesn't look too Lively right
now though uh too energetic um I think
if he wants to get this game towards
safety there we go he'll happily trade
off all the Rooks and uh Robert that
Dynamic you mentioned queen of Knight
versus queen and Bishop yeah maybe some
chances long term so Dennis shouldn't
relax too early never relax against the
top players of course but ultimately
Tanya I think your prediction draw and
Armageddon looks by far the most likely
outcome right now and you mentioned
Queen and Knight versus queen and Bishop
it gives chances to the side with the
Knight because they can get tricky but
if even the Queens come off if it's just
a pure Bishop versus knight end game
with pawns on both flanks it's actually
white with the bishop a longrange piece
that can start pushing a little bit the
king can come out the bishop can be on
D5 controlling more of the board so it's
really about who manages to get the
ideal trades in uh but I think both
players are making quick moves quick
improving moves and we are going to see
either the Queens come off or the Rooks
come off but I highly doubt that this
will head to a pure Bishop was Knight
because in that case Dennis will be the
one who will be pushing yeah that would
not be good to get Bishop versus knight
I think that with a knight where it
currently sits it covers a many key
squares and don't be surprised when
Magnus throws his H Pawn forward right
now is one option he could also play on
The Queen side I just feel like some of
Black's moves are a little bit easier to
play than whites this open D file it
looks just as strong as the open C file
but I I don't know something about this
position is
making it difficult for me to see what
White's actual plan is David do you see
anything for either side honestly and
how you can play for more than just
equality it's tough I think ultimately
the position is equal I would have said
actually until this last move that
Magnus is going to play his trademarks
he's going to play H5 just to tickle
pretend that he's pushing some pawns
forward on that flank uh towards the
white king then he might play A5 pretend
he'll push the B Pawn as well on the
other flank but I think magnus's mood is
uh different right now than it was
earlier in the day he's just happy to
guide this game towards safety and um
yeah Rook to D4 might be the only way to
imbalance things you pointed it out
there Robert on the on the board Rook D4
would have changed the pawn structure
potentially but uh now that the Rooks
are off it looks too symmetrical look at
the pawn structure pretty much almost
symmetrical should still be a draw but
queen of Knight we
mentioned we choose black slightly if I
had to uh I wanted to ask the question
though assuming that this one stays
level who do you you think is the
happier player and who do you think
wants black in the
Armageddon wow that's a that's a tough
one but I think it's a really important
question David because I think both
players will try and get the result odds
they will try to get the black pieces
but then how low can you actually go to
attain that I don't know who's going to
win the Armageddon bid but I am
predicting a a bid around 6 and a half
minutes by these players what about you
Robert I think that denn
yeah he has shown a willingness to get
low on the clock he also just brought
his King out into the open you you can
use your kings as weapons in the end
game everybody although now black is
aiming at a pawn But to answer the
Armageddon question yeah I think that
Magnus he's willing to go quite low he's
been way faster in this match thus far
for
Dennis yeah I feel like seven minutes is
probably the lower limit just because he
constantly finds himself in time trouble
and he won't have increment to rely on
so I feel I feel like Dennis will
probably end up with the white
pieces guys you got answer your question
too we're not going to let you off the
hook so easily I was about to deflect
and try to dodge that one um but I agree
I think uh both players will be quite
Keen especially Magnus now after this
last game to get the black pieces Magnus
lost with white so why not try to get
black um I also wanted to point out the
accuracy this game I mean it's such a
high class game and sometimes ultimately
a drawers a logical result in chess 98%
accur rece for both players um yeah I
think Magnus would love black and he
might go lower than we expect I think
he'll be super Keen to get the draw odds
but right now a pause for Magnus a bit
of a frown on the camera do you think
he'll try and uh grind this one we keep
saying tickle Dennis here creates some
threats Pawn H5 we predicted actually
both the Rooks pawns starting to march
here
Robert typical Magnus and he may even
throw that pawn one step further because
if white responds with G4 this may be
hard to visualize for some you're just
giving black all of the dark squares so
when your opponent has a knight and you
have a light Square Bishop how can you
control dark squares if your pawns are
on dark squares since they capture
diagonally so you have to be very
careful here if you're Dennis laic I
know that the bar is in the middle the
draw seems to be the likely result but I
we've seen it from Magnus countless
times in his illustrious career you take
one move off and suddenly you're in
trouble so does white stop that but give
black this very important G4 Square
looks a bit worrisome to my eyes do you
allow black to play H4 and then harm
White's Pawn structure also looks
problematic I do think that Dennis has
to invest some serious time here and
he's already down almost three minutes
on the clock why should Magnus just make
a draw actually his latest move allows
black to play H4 this is risk-free chess
from the number one
player and uh on your point Rob Pawn to
H4 if it's ever captured uh Magnus will
smile he'll love that he'll happily
throw a pawn away white Pawn structure
will be totally ruined with Queens on
the board you cannot allow that the
black queen will happily at some point
sneak over towards the king side the
Black Knight will have access to some
Outpost so a lot of viewers at home
might be wondering why Pawn to H4 for
black it's a pawn sacrifice you'll
giving it away but uh no you're breaking
the opponent's structure and wow I'm
really surprised Magnus didn't go for it
but oh okay no I'm showing I'm showing
what's happening if this G he did not go
for this maybe he's for later but I just
wanted to highlight that F4 and the dark
Square so B5 was play no I guess David
you are correct he didn't go for it but
is it going anywhere I guess is the
question Tanya I want to just highlight
the idea behind this last move B5 I
think after H4 Dennis intended to play
Queen to C4 which is why he made this
retreating move Bishop to B3 we've been
talking about the different trades in
the position that how a queen trade
would actually favor white so B5 was a
really nice prophylactic move by Magnus
taking away a key Square which would
have forced to trade because it's not
only offering that Queen exchange but
also that F7 weakness uh which is why
Magnus did not rush with H4 played B5
controlling the square and now Dennis is
offering a bishop trade on D5 and I
think if Magnus picks this up are you
going to uh go into a King Pawn ending
will you calculate that well none of
that neither of the players want it
Magnus steps back attacking the H3 Pawn
the king comes back and we're expecting
that move H4 to land about now
especially if Magnus wants to win this
game or if he wants to keep any winning
chances alive but feels like hesitation
here Robert indecision from the world
number one Magnus just drops his King
back doesn't necessarily improve things
he's coming towards the center hinting
he might take the white Bishop but still
yet to go for that H4 um why do you
think he's waiting why isn't he pulling
the trigger and going for it well thank
you for the hint because I was thinking
that Knight takes D5 made White's life
easy but you're absolutely correct that
especially if the Queen's come off there
the black king can Dart to the center
and black may just win the pawn where it
lands on D5 so white needs to be very
careful I'm not so sure about some of
these decisions from both players
frankly but the pawn on B4 is it a
weakness is it a strength you do get a
Pawn on a dark Square your Bishop can't
help defend that later on but that also
freezes Black's Pawn on a light Square
so your Bishop can go after that this is
Magnus Carlson will he push will he
press T it does feel like his style of
endgame here but is there enough life
left and that's the big question is
there enough life left are there enough
pieces left and to my eyes it just feels
like you don't have enough resources to
make that much of it but that said with
this bishop on D5 still underpin with
this bishop on D5 always this trade
being offered I think this is the best
position that Magnus has had all game
and it just comes down to how ambitious
will he feel does he want to play this
till the very end does he want to go
into an Armageddon or is danovic getting
ambitious F4 was not a move on my
radar Robert I see the expression on
your face I think it matches mine I mean
this feels desperate F4 looks ambitious
but it's also going to weaken the white
king the white porn structure is never
going to be intact anymore huge huge
gamble there from Dennis LA with two
minutes left and I think for Dennis he
was tired of sitting and waiting feeling
like Magnus was getting the upper hand
slowly but surely but F4 here and even
if you swap pawns on the Square that now
the dark squares are really vulnerable
in a move like Queen C7 maybe you could
start with Queen C7 in some of these
positions as well because the white king
is exposed also on the second rank so I
don't know about that decision the EV uh
engine the evaluation bar it says that
it was incorrect but maybe it will pay
off because it does muddy the water so
it's not just one-sided in magnus's
favor
IDE on the board I like the fact that
Dennis pre moved G takes F4 because
every second counts at this point down
to two minutes and going to C7 hitting
that pawn just hinting at coming in and
behind that's the most uncomfortable
thing in chess when an opponent's Queen
is down uh kind of in your gr down on
the first second ranks and uh I mean
pretty much Unstoppable the black queen
is coming in One Direction or the other
yes white can go and take the B5 Pawn
but you might just get checkmated along
the way so um you have to be really
careful now this is where Queen and
Knight if they get to attack together
will be so dangerous right T White's
Bishop might not be able to participate
in the defense on the DWS yeah some
really big committal decisions taken by
Dennis the last couple of moves and I
think what he's calculating right now is
can he Force matters can he go E5
forcing the trade on D3 but you have to
be really careful uh for sorry forcing
the trades on D5 you have to be super
careful because that allows Black's
Queen to infiltrate you might lose the
A3 Pawn with checks and then are you you
in time to give perpetuals he doesn't go
for it he falls back with the queen
defending that f for Pawn Robert you
don't like this move well the blue arrow
tells the full story here Queen D6
freezes white the queen went to the pawn
f4s defense now Queen on D6 threatens
Knight takes E4 because the bishop on D5
is pinned and in certain end games you
can even just take this bishop on D5
King E7 it was a miss this deserves the
X sometimes I throw that X out the
window and say no that's a perfect L
fine move Queen D6 not easy to play
because using a pin but walking into
potential forks and things of that
nature are not easy but I do feel like
Dennis is in trouble here I don't really
care what the engine says it's the the
position of the white king it's that the
white pieces feel a bit clumsy he needs
to do something fast otherwise he's just
going to lose he's also down now to just
53 52
seconds we saw the first clue as well
that Dennis is getting nervous on the on
the camera I'm just watching him there
there was a slight almost imperceptible
Shake of the head suddenly scratching
his head as well he's realizing oh
there's no natural moves and 40 seconds
left again the clock is ticking Magnus
inserting the upper hand yet again on
the clock and Tanya you mentioned it
when you're low on time it's natural you
want to force the issue and he's going
for it now he's trying to force the
trade of Knight for Bishop what do you
think uh is this going to save Dennis
well the evalar helps us turns out that
it is a right moment and the right
decision the big question to me at that
moment was that if black was to capture
on D5 give checks with the queen when
black wins that A3 Pawn that Side Pawn
that white has can Black's King be under
danger are there enough checks is there
a Perpetual but I think with magnus's
King now placed on E7 these lines work
out for Dennis he's just going to
capture the D5 Pawn Magnus if he comes
in with the queen starts getting greedy
I think there's a Perpetual against the
E7 King here there's just one thing that
Dennis needs to be alert about if he
brings his King to the third rank the
could be a sneaky check on B3 trying to
create a pass Pawn so Dennis he has a
drawing mechanism of his own the black
king is in actually in a bad position
because once the black queen leaves
Queen D6 to B8 and back to D6 you put it
on a yo-yo string it's going to deliver
a draw but Magnus he poses a really
challenging question to Dennis now can
you trade Queens because that could be a
losing King and pwn in game and Dennis
has 30 seconds to figure it
out wow what a tough decision now Dennis
he has to risk either he has to trust
Magnus and Dodge the queen trade or he
has to risk a king and porn end game
Queen to C5 check instead I think a wise
decision if in doubt take the safer
option King and por games are pure
calculation it's move by move you're
either winning or losing or drawing like
nothing in between you can't just wing
it so Queen to C5 check now the black
king uh Tanya you mentioned it's not
entirely safe do you think it's going to
step forward is Magnus going to be
feeling brave wow there we go he answers
the question question for me and a
mistake by Dennis he moves his own King
forward but this gives Magnus the time
to actually infiltrate with his Queen
and now I think the point is that he can
go Pawn hunting because Black's King is
going to March up the light squares and
be safe and then might not be a
Perpetual then that's exactly what's
happening here but the players they
don't have any blue arrows they don't
have an evaluation bar to the side
telling them that this is the moment but
for Dennis lack he's been hanging on by
a thread for the last bunch of moves
here Queen D3 check and as you said t
the King by thread and needle can use
those light squares and it is going to
be a problem for White and the King G3
what a natural move to play to avoid any
kind of queen trade Queen D5 was going
to offer Queen trade with Black's King
in a favorable spot David will Magnus
find Queen D3 first and King F5 second
yes because Robert I want to point out
don't play King F5 now if you play King
F5 enter with the black king you lose on
the spot the white Pawn will step
forward to E6 with a discovered check
and you have to retreat with the King
taking this Pawn you get m in the center
of the board so process of elimination
you cannot Advance your king first you
have to go for a check and only then
once your queen is safe drive forward
with your own King it's a race between
Kings right now and uh Magnus we think
we he's gonna go for it do you see the
blue arrow here G5 check I assume if
Pawn takes there might be Queen C4 is
that one of those ideas that you can
play to force the Queens off the board
and get a pass Pawn that is incredibly
deep and it goes to show that pawn
quality it often outpaces Pawn quantity
and especially end game like this G5
check is played I'm gonna freak out
because that just looks impossible there
are no Protectors of that square and
white has two pieces covering it we're
all going to fall out of our chairs if
G5 check is played but Magnus has 25
seconds always look for check first
that's the moral of the story either
they're very good or you rule them out
and you look for something uh better but
okay he's really going low on the clock
he plays the more natural move King to
F5 missed opportunity maybe winning
there some checkmates or queen trades
and now wow blue arrow says the best
move to keep the balance the only move
is to give away the pawn and Dennis has
done it he's going for Perpetual check
can the black king escape from the white
Queen's gaze right now oh no more checks
suddenly why does he sacrific the pawn
why is this genius because of the King
march now it's Dennis being brave and
adventurous with the white king
yeah I I didn't see another check and I
was really surprised but like you said
the black queen needs to defend all
these checks and he goes Pawn hunting
but now there's got to be a Perpetual
now you start just checking the king and
you don't allow Black's Queen you
probably give a check from C5 making
sure that the black queen cannot come to
defense he does exactly
that we got to be careful Dennis the
black queen can swoop back to block some
of these checks as she just does there
and Dennis did he miss that one he lent
back in his chair 2 seconds he's playing
purely on the increment now shaking his
head the black king is going to slide
away slink away to safety and the white
king might get checkmated be careful
here a queen trade what an offer and
it's a draw so it was brilliant by
Dennis LZ apparently this is a hold but
not after that mve he had to play B5 a
moment ago now it's too
slow start a race Dennis lazic but he
had no time to calculate shaking his
head now the black porns are going to
much forward to Victory heartbreak he
was one accurate move away so close but
Magnus is going to do it endgame magic
again now we
go he does it he gets the win in and
that was an insane insane finish what
just happened there David we saw the bar
go up and down it's a heartbreaking
moment but danis lazovic was so close to
getting the job done to take it to
Armageddon so close but not close close
enough as Magnus Carson works that
endgame magic pure Instinct there from
both players at the end no time on the
clock but uh it was Dennis who made the
final mistake in a complicated Queen end
game we can forgive him it was a
difficult difficult position but he
ultimately did let it slip right at the
death after great defense but Magnus as
always seems to emerge victorious in
these end games what an amazing end game
that was and for Dennis lack you know he
took it to Magnus he pushed his pawns it
was in accurate at first but then he
jettison the pawn brought his King
forward and even offered a queen trade
that while black had some winning plans
once the queens were traded it
objectively was the right decision so
his intuition is unreal he's just 17
years old he'll continue to sharpen his
play his openings his Pace but he was
really every bit of Magnus Carlson's
equal until those final few moves when
Magnus was able to escape with Victory
and thus the
match holding his own in game to
bouncing back in game three getting that
win in taking it to game four Janice
lazovic kept it so under control in that
one as well and we saw the bar go all
crazy it was a yo-yo position and maybe
David at some point you can just go
through those last couple of moves CU
there was so much action that happened
but in the end Magnus Carlson's endgame
technique prevailed Magnus Carlson goes
into the grand final of the chessel
Masters he knocks down Dennis lavic who
will have one more live who will be
waiting in the losers final to play the
winner of yan naishi and Ali Reza fuja
David that was one of the craziest ends
that we've just witnessed there were
moments when it looked like Dennis had
it then moments where it looked like
Magnus has it what happened there it was
Topsy Turvy a roller coaster this is why
we always say study your end games
practice your end games Queen end games
though are the trickiest of the bunch
and uh I did did want to show the moment
where it all turned it actually turned
multiple times in the space of a few
seconds in the space of just one or two
moves as Dennis went from a drawn
position to a losing position back to a
draw and then ultimately let it slip and
um if we can show that on the board um
yeah Dennis just with no time left he
made a very human error and uh really
unfortunate there but uh Magnus
ultimately he pounced on the opportunity
and uh he's just so Ruth when he gets
even the smallest of chances uh so it
was here that things started to go wrong
for Dennis lazovic the most difficult
move I would say to keep the balance
King into H6 finding safety Behind Enemy
Lines really not obvious at all instead
he played the move Queen to E5 given a
question mark and it was a mistake but
it was a gamble that could well have
paid off Magnus missed the winning move
Pawn to F6 check this would have been
simply incredible we would have seen a
race after the Queen's disappear Magnus
pushing the H Pawn for Glory now but the
white B Pawn more most importantly can
be stopped by the black king the black
king is within this box stops the white
pawn and the black pawn Queens first
Magnus missed this with no time on his
clock traded queens and suddenly it's
back to a draw after King to E7 Dennis
could have initiated a race that he
would have emerged well from uh he would
have kept the balance with Pawn to B5
when the black king moves away the white
king comes in and the white ewn runs
forward but he took his foot off the
pedal just for one move instead
retreating King to F4 but losing time in
temp and Tempe in end games is fatal
King to F4 allowed the black king to
step forward and the black pawns to
start rolling it was a matter of time
then and Magnus converted ups and downs
twists and turns but uh as usual it is
that man again Magnus
Carson beautifully explained there David
just how rich and complex this end game
was and how difficult this end game was
and in the end Magnus Carlson did prove
he gets the win he gets the job done
Dennis laswick in the elimination
bracket and don't go anywhere cuz we
will be back with Magnus Carlson joining
us for an interview see you in just a
[Music]
few
this is John John loves to study chess
this is David David loves to study chess
as well but
efficiently John spends more time
setting up the board and figuring out
what's on the page of his book than he
gets to
study David likes to take it easy and
use his time
[Music]
wisely David has finished his exercise
for today
John should try the
[Music]
same I'm here with Magnus Carlson world
number one and to many greatest chess
player of all time we're going to ask
him a few questions I'm going to name a
sport you have to tell me the greatest
of all time mhm sounds good yeah
basketball LeBron
James soccer Messi I agree with both
baseball
Barry
BNS what did he say Okay football like
American
football Tom Brady I guess okay yeah
good one uh tennis jovic
golf
tiger Fair poker
doson that's a unique one
chess gar Kasparov are you allowed to
say
yourself I don't know if I'm loud but I
think Gary is the best of all time still
chess
boxing I'm on Hamilton I agree we're
going to play this or that would you
rather go on a cruise or a road trip
road trip comedy or thriller comedy
coffee or tea tea but only slightly
preferably neither how do you get
energized the
sun cats or dogs cats but I like dogs
too it's like a this or that is a little
bit tough with you you like everything
shower or bath oh shower for sure okay I
don't have the patience to take baths
are you a morning person or a night owl
Night Owl for sure would you rather get
on a phone call or text message text
prob I feel like the answer for you is
neither feel like it's just usually
yes just go sunrise or sunset sunrise
winter or summer summer how many beers
would it take for you to drink for me to
beat you in a class chess game that's a
very difficult question uh cuz I'd
probably sober up during the game so I'd
probably have to keep drinking probably
start with 20 and take it from there 20
okay how what's the size of the cup um
pints wow okay 20 name your price if you
have to chess box um $10 million do you
prefer to play chess on a computer over
the board or on your phone I rarely play
on my phone I I would say I prefer to
play on the computer in your entire
career have you ever had a day where you
went I think this guy might be as good
as me in
chess
no uh well I mean not not not you know
since not the last 10 years for sure
okay has it ever
been this guy might be kind of close to
me if I have a bad day yeah uh I would
say Fabia his best was um very closing
classical for sure my other question was
going to be who do you think is the
second best chess player in the world so
I suppose yeah I think Fabian corana is
the is the second second best player
thank you Magnus for sitting down with
us and doing these rapid fire questions
now get out of
here
I we're back we're being joined by the
three times reigning tour Champion world
number one Magnus Carson Magnus
congratulations on that win it was a
fantastic match to watch a big fight
take us through the match uh what did
you make of it and how was
it um yeah obviously it became very
difficult after
uh after game uh
three um I I
mean the honestly like the for most of
game three and and uh also game four I
was just pretty tilted by the way the
matches was going but
um you know I think both in in game one
and uh in game four like he's like he's
a kind of player always thinks for and
like sometimes he plays well under time
pressure but I don't think you can rely
on playing well in those situations all
the time so a couple of times he he were
sh on time and he eventually cracked it
was not
easy Magnus game one you won it so
convincingly and we were also impressed
watching that and then game two you put
so much pressure but then there was this
great resistance from him was that
frustrating in game two to just see him
hold on with that
draw well I mean he also had an
opportunity which I realized right after
I made the move like I blended my H Pawn
due to a fork which is like doubly silly
cuz that fork was there on the board a
few movs ago so he actually had a chance
to take over there as well uh but yeah
apart from that um he did really well I
wouldn't expect I wouldn't say that I
ever like expected
to
um uh to to win uh but I I you know I
certainly
um I was certainly hoping so um and
yeah um I I think I think so he made a
positional Mistake by trading on C6 and
then going Queen D4 CU it looks like he
Saddles me with with um a weak Pawn on
on C6 and a bad Bishop but the reality
is is a bit um different since I can
just maneuver the Knight around my king
will find a beautiful Square on D6 and
so on but yeah for sure after that he
did did well and after that the match
was was just a mess
[Music]
and um you know with some luck he could
have uh could have won what happened in
game three
uh I just you know I started to play a
bit indifferently he did really well for
a while um finding a lot of lot of very
good moves uh and hly
like
um I'd sort of I'd seen from afar that
he could play this Knight D5 move after
ab4 but then I forgot about it and I
realized like immediately as I
played um the move A4 so that oh Knight
D5 is happening so then the exchange
sack was more tilt than
anything anything
else um and uh yeah after that I mean I
thought that was coming back in the game
with my Aon but then I couldn't find
anything and um I think he did did well
um but yeah that was pretty
pretty tting but you got to give him got
to give him credit for um for finding a
lot of um a lot of big moves in that
game yeah it was very impressive to
watch and we saw you react at the end of
game three did you feel like you missed
some chance at the end there were you
just what happened there no it was just
frustrating um I didn't feel that i'
missed any particular chance I just
thought I was was close to coming back
and I couldn't find it and it was such
an unnecessary loss in in general so
that was just annoying me that because I
I
felt I felt after I'd won the first game
like he's usually very solid but unless
like you give him chances it doesn't
create create them that easily which is
which is you know
perfectly normal at 17
um with the classical rating house is
not supposed to uh be uh be creating a
lot of chances against the against the
best players but um so yeah that was
just felt so unnecessary to let him back
into much that way um
and yeah of course the fourth game as I
said I was pretty tilted when I started
I play
I play this line that I usually play
only when I'm tilted I just give away
the bishop pair try and play solid not
to think too
much and I mean fortunately I managed to
even though I was a bit worse I managed
to equalize after that and there was
nothing special going on and after that
you know I can start
using technique which pretty much
regardless of the state of mind I can do
I can do okay hm was there a moment that
you think that this is going to go into
uh an
armagen yeah I wasn't worried about
Armageddon particularly um I was just
trying to play and and see but I mean I
I
certainly missed
opportunities and he could have taken it
into the armag him but I wouldn't say I
was thinking too much about it or
worried about it
M we've been so amazed with Dennis's run
in this entire chessable Masters and
also the resistance he put against you
today with this experience of playing
against him what do you think it is
about his style and his play that that
lets him survive these formats against
the very best in the
world he's just fundamentally very
[Music]
sound it's good
understanding um so he's yeah he's it's
not easy to to break down and think with
some some experience he going to become
a top top
player yeah have you been impressed with
how he plays with such little time on
the
clock yeah
um as I said like he plays rather slowly
so he gets into a lot of time trouble
and I mean I wouldn't recommend that
necessarily as a sustainable approach
especially with 2C increment but it's
certainly a sign of um of huge talent
that he can he can keep it going at
least sometimes even though in those
situations and Magus such a match an up
and down match is that also
psychologically mentally
exhausting no it's just
annoying all right fa I'm going to put
in some final chat questions to you
before we let you go and uh yeah just a
couple more minutes uh the first one is
by I'm going to butcher this name it's
ker guard and he wants to know how do
you mentally reset for a new game after
what happened in game
three I don't I was just tilted when I
started you know we didn't have any time
in between the games really either so I
was still tilted but you know it's a new
game to
play but no I didn't
reset
you still made it work for yourself uh
the next question is by wear 15 and he
says what do you think about this new
format this season Magnus it's 10
minutes with a 2C increment very
different from uh last season we've been
having some chaotic end games which are
fun for fans maybe not so much for the
players how does this different time
control change the
Dynamics yeah I think that's Su it up
pretty well it's definitely stressful
for for the players
[Music]
um and um I think a lot of players are
struggling with it a bit to find um the
Rhythm so I think it's um he sums it up
pretty well but you know as long as it's
good for for the fans that's um that's
um obviously very important which one do
you prefer 15 plus 3 or the 10 plus
two I like this
I like this format it makes it you know
anything that can make a day of work a
little bit
shorter it's good not to say that that I
don't don't um don't enjoy en enjoy uh
these tournaments it's
just um you know means you have more
time to do other things as
well all right and one more question for
you from the chat what is mag is looking
forward to in
2024 uh I'm looking forward to a lot of
things but uh in the near future I'm
looking forward to um to the final uh
that's going to be on Wednesday I
suppose and I'm very much looking
forward to playing um freestyle chess um
classical uh St a few days after that's
something I wanted for for a long time
and last going for the the first time
that we'll have Fisher random In
classical
format it it is uh and
um you know playing these games now
rapid
chess um with kind of normal chest and
then uh and then fish ROM chest uh fish
ROM classical later I mean that's pretty
much what I what I want so in in that
sense you know this is a good week is
Fisher random becoming your favorite
format or one of your favorite
formats I
wouldn't it's it's hard to say though
cuz I really like Blitz and Rapid with
normal chest still especially
lits so a bit a mix of a mix of several
things is
nice all right variety and finally
Before I Let You Go Magnus Grand Final
coming up who are you expecting to fight
uh in that is there a player do you have
a preference who you'd want to meet in
the Grand
Final
um I
think uh see probably ala is a slight
favorite against
Yan um and
[Music]
then yeah this the other match is fairly
fairly open I would say guess Al resa is
would maybe be my B at this moment to go
through but then again he has to
win two
matches it's very hard to
say so you think ala is the favorite and
is he the opponent that you'd like to
play in the Grand Final he was an
opponent you wanted in the world
championship Once Upon a
Time yeah I love playing ala he always
um puts a lot of pressure he plays very
ambitiously so I'd love to to play him
but you know it's a privilege to be in
the final regardless so from I'm play
from I play
I'm yeah I think this is your fifth out
of six Champions chest St finals uh
counting last season as well so you've
made a habit out of it uh Magnus I know
David joked about you having a rest day
today but you've got two rest days
before the Grand Final that's quite a
bit of time how do you plan to spend
it um I plan to travel to Germany and
then uh you know enjoy my last day in in
Spain
tomorrow all right you don't get one but
you get two rest days enjoy get some
rest Magnus we'll see you in the Grand
Final thank
you
bye Magnus scon there after his win
against Dennis lawick makes it to Grand
Final gets two days off will be flying
to Germany we'll see him back meanwhile
we will have big action in the losers
bracket as y Nai fights ala fja in the
loser semi-finals the winner will play
against Dennis lack a big fight coming
up Robert David Magnus picked Ali RZA as
a slight favorite to take uh this to the
Grand Final what's your take on
this well I think by the odds Dennis
lavic he might be the odds onfair
because he gets a buy he awaits the win
winner of Ali Rea fua versus yanami but
as Magnus said Ali Rea he always brings
the fight he's such a fun player to face
off against but who knows in this field
yand pomi super tough finding some
Rhythm there too I don't know who is
going to make it through but I do know
that Magnus Carlson even when he's not
his happiest he's still playing baller
chess yeah Magnus uh he made it through
that's what the top sports players the
top sports teams do even when they know
that they're best they grind out the
result they find a way to get the job
done and uh I think he was trying to
dodge the topic there he doesn't want a
rematch against Dennis lazic because
today was so tough but nice to see
Magnus relieved and uh in a good mood
after that
Victory and that was such a big fight
and I think the players also enjoy when
there's a big fight on the board and you
win a match like this uh and then David
as he said he gets two days off he
wanted today off now he gets two days to
enjoy himself but he's got a big Grand
Final to look forward to as well
and let's bring up after this day of the
chessable Ms and what a day it's been
let's bring up our chessable masters
standing presented by the wealth
management partners of the Champions
chess tour Julius bear and here we have
it it is Vladimir fed and Jose Martinez
who got eliminated today they go back
home while fed Martinez Maxim vrab
Wesley so it's the end of the road for
them the action continues
uh and a big paycheck as well for all of
them and I'm sure Robert we're going to
see some of these names back on the tour
we certainly will Wesley so did not have
his best showing in division one but he
made it to the finals of the Champions
chess Tour live event in Toronto so
between Wesley Maxim Jose and Vladimir
fosa the season has just begun it's not
easy to make it back here in fact some
of the biggest names in chess are not in
division one it goes to show that
there's no guarantees not in the
Champions chess tour
2024 yeah we saw those four spots still
there in those standings presented by
Julius barar and players don't want to
fill in those spots too quickly they
want to get into the Grand Final and
before we say goodbye to chat before we
sign off David your final thoughts about
the action that we witnessed
today oh so much action I love that
seesaw match between Nomi and fed of
earlier I just love the fight in Dennis
lazic we're seeing a superstar just
evolving and growing before our very
eyes but ultimately it was Magnus
Carlson who took over um just a great
day of Chess and really shaping up
nicely for this final stretch of the
tournament now yeah it really is and the
drama does continue tomorrow chat Robert
David myself we will be back with all of
you to take you through the action as
the players fight to get that final spot
to challenge Magnus Carlson in the
chessable masters Grand Final it's going
to be a big day of Chess we'll be back
we'll see you then it's been fun it's a
good night from
[Music]
us so y he's got his face in his hands
right now
David we see him a minute down maybe
soon fall down yeah I will take FIA here
all day
long
[Music]
oh